Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between MrBeast Burger
in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In the US, a MrBeast Beast-style burger
comes in double and triple.
The Beast-style burger in the
UK also comes in two sizes,
the double and a triple.
It's dripping grease.
Holy sheesh!
Can you see how wet this is?
Let's weigh a triple burger now
to see whose burger is bigger.
Look how gross these
scales are, by the way.
A Beast-style triple in
the UK weighs 270 grams.
Joe: The US triple Beast-style burger
weighs 290 grams.
In the US, MrBeast Burger has one size
of crinkle-cut fries.
They come in either
unseasoned or seasoned.
In the UK, we also just
have one size of fries.
And they come as either seasoned
or as unseasoned.
Speaking of fries, the menu
offers a Chris-style burger.
Who's Chris?
His burger has fries on it,
and for this they charge
you an extra dollar,
or in the UK an extra British pound.
This got me wondering, how
many fries come on this burger,
and does that warrant
an extra dollar charge?
Let's count and find out.
One, two, three.
[fast-forwarding]
That seems reasonably generous.
27 fries on my Chris-style burger.
But what about the cost of the fries?
Let's count how many
fries come in an order.
One, two, three.
Counting that one, 92.
Let's go by volume. For an extra dollar,
you get 33 grams of fries.
An order of fries,
total is 133 grams.
How do we figure this out?
You're paying 4 pence.
3 per chip.
We had 33 grams,
equal a dollar for the Chris style, right?
How much was it?
£1.17 worth of chips in the burger.
I think technically you're paying, like,
an extra pound for this one
compared to the Beast burger.
So you actually are,
you are getting slightly
more than you pay for.
[crew laughing]
By 17p.
So if our math is correct,
it looks like on the Chris-style burger,
per gram, each fry costs 3 cents.
But if you get the
crinkle-cut fries on the side,
each fry per gram costs 4 cents.
So you're actually getting
a better deal on fries
if you get them in the Chris
burger than separately.
That's pretty nice.
That took way longer than it
should have, and I'm sorry.
Here is everything you'll find
at a MrBeast Burger in the UK.
Here's everything you can find in the US
at a MrBeast Burger.
There's a slight problem with our usual
exclusives approach to this section,
which is namely that
the UK doesn't have any.
Everything on the menu here
is also available in the US.
However, I do have a suspicion
that some of these things
might be slightly different.
So we're going to take a look.
The only food exclusive
the US has over the UK
is in the US, you can get a
MrBeast Impossible burger,
made with the Impossible beef.
That's because at the
time of recording this,
Impossible beef is not
available in the UK.
That's because it
contains a key ingredient
called soy leghemoglobin, aka heme.
According to Impossible Foods,
it's what makes some meats taste so meaty
and creates the bleeding effect.
Heme is classified as GRAS,
generally recognized as safe, in the US.
However, it does not
have regulatory approval
in the UK or the EU just yet,
although Impossible Foods do
say they're working on it.
Besides that, the only
drink you can get in the US,
can't get in the UK is Sierra Mist.
UK, consider yourself lucky.
Sierra Mist sucks.
Start down this end with the classic.
So, we have the MrBeast-style double.
Two smashed patties. There's cheese,
and then there's also pickles,
chopped onions, some
mustard, and some ketchup.
I love smash burgers,
and I wish more places did smash burgers.
You end up with these incredibly
crispy bits on the outside.
Do you see this? That's just pure flavor.
Mm. It's like beef candy. It's brilliant.
Really good.
That's pretty good. I do like this.
I don't know if I would consider
this a smash patty, though.
Tasty, juicy.
Then of course we have
the Beast-style triple,
which has the same toppings
but an extra beef patty.
The Chris style. What up,
Chris? Whoever you are.
Fries and bacon on the sandwich.
Yeah, sort of just OK.
So, this is the UK Chris-style burger.
We have bun, we have
fries with some cheese,
two beef patties,
and on the bottom, just
one piece of bacon,
and it's kind of that, like, cheap bacon.
I associate this with buffets,
particularly when you go
to an all-inclusive
resort in central Europe.
I have to try this one. It looks so good.
Mm-hmm. They didn't skimp on the fries.
This thing is dense.
So, this is the Karl's deluxe in the UK.
What they've done is, for some reason,
only flipped one of the burger buns,
and then they've kind of used that to
create a grilled-cheese effect,
which in the UK we call a cheese toastie.
But then within that you have a beef patty
with cheese on both sides
as well as some grilled onions.
The Chandler style.
There's nothing on this.
Just burgers and cheese. Like,
this food is made for 10-year-olds.
Chandler, come on, man. What's going on?
This is a very, very basic cheeseburger.
It's just bun, cheese,
meat, cheese, meat, bun.
It just feels a little bit
like when you're a little kid
and all you want is a
hamburger with bread and beef.
It's too dry. Come on,
Chandler. Live a little, man.
Get some sauce involved. Maybe
even some pickles. Who knows?
I don't know what the
Nashville tastes like
over there in the UK.
Sticking tenders in here. But this one,
crunchy.
And, of course, they also have the option
of just a regular chicken sandwich.
In a weird way, it kind of
reminds me of the McChicken,
but, like, not as flavored.
Any fast-food place,
this would be the
dollar-menu chicken sandwich.
This is $9?!
Bro!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is the Nashville hot ... [laughs]
This is so offensive to
the people of Nashville.
People of Nashville, look away now,
because the UK is about to
start another revolutionary war.
So, the problem is, in the
UK, no one really knows
what Nashville hot chicken
is supposed to look like.
So fast-food chains can
get away with serving
things like this, and
people don't know enough
to call them out on it.
What is this? Come on.
What they've done, as far as I can tell,
is just take standard chicken tenders,
and then I think they've added
maybe some of the seasoning
from the seasoned fries
and then tried to pass that
off as a hot chicken sandwich.
I'm not good with spice.
There's nothing going on there.
Zero Scovilles. That's not
Nashville, nor is it hot.
You can also just get a
chicken-tender sandwich.
I don't understand what the
difference is, particularly.
This one has pickles on it.
I just wish we could up
our chicken game in the UK.
At the moment we're not
doing the best job of it.
And unfortunately, MrBeast Burger
is not our hero when it comes to that.
So, Karl making a second
appearance on the menu.
Apparently he has a grilled cheese
that is two top buns, flipped over,
with cheese smashed in the middle of it.
This is 6 bucks.
Oh, that's really funny.
How much is a loaf of bread
and a bunch of slices of American cheese?
You can make, like, 20 of these.
This thing looks quite sad.
I think both of the buns
are supposed to be flipped.
Quite interesting aesthetic.
The cheese hasn't really melted properly,
so it's not stuck to this.
So it's just a very smooth,
shiny layer of cheese.
These are your seasoned fries.
Eh, you know.
It does give me a slight
Nando's vibe to it,
in terms of the heat level
and some of the flavor profiles as well.
Like, almost like a
peri-peri seasoning on this.
MrBeast burger also offers
something called Beast-style fries,
which comes loaded with
caramelized onions,
American cheese, pickles,
mayo, ketchup, and mustard.
This is it right here.
I don't know about this, guys.
Maybe not the most visually appealing.
However, I like the idea of
fries and pickles together.
Cheers.
I really like these.
These are really good.
And one dessert, a chocolate chip cookie.
This is a pretty good cookie.
That's not bad.
[crunching]
[thudding]
This is, like, pretty stale.
Obviously we're a bit lacking
in exclusives in the UK,
but maybe I can take some
preexisting menu items
and combine them to create
a Harry-style burger.
Trademark Harry Style.
The Chandler style, which
was the very plain one.
I'm going to take some of the
fake Nashville hot chicken,
which is not very hot at all.
Land that straight on top.
Actually, I think this will benefit from
some of the moisture on this bun,
so I'm going to keep that as well.
So, we're going for MrBeast-style fries,
'cause I quite liked the Chris
style with the fries on it.
Here goes. The Harry Styles.
You know what? We might
have done something there.
I actually don't mind the
combination of chicken and beef.
I think that kind of works.
Oh, God, what have I done?
They were too preoccupied with
whether or not they could,
they didn't stop to think about
whether or not they should.
But honestly, don't
hate it. Give it a try.
So, for my signature burger,
here's what I'm going to do.
I think this is a really good idea.
I'm excited about this.
I'm going to take a Karl's grilled cheese
and a second Karl's grilled cheese,
and mine's going to be
the Beast-style burger,
but instead of buns,
it's two grilled cheeses.
Check this out. Grilled cheese.
Double patties. Should
I put fries on it too?
Yuelei: Yeah.
Joe: Why not?
We'll make it a Chris style,
because these fries have all
the seasoning and stuff on it.
They have all the ketchup
and have all the sauces
and everything on it.
Ooh, and there's caramelized onions too.
OK, there. They got the Beast burger,
or, the Beast-style burger.
This is the Joe-style burger.
We can also call this,
I've been told I look like old MrBeast.
So this could be old-MrBeast-style burger,
or MrBeast-with-no-serotonin burger,
or I-kind-of-look-like-that-guy-
from-"Game-of-Thrones" burger.
So whatever you want to
call it, but here we go.
Oh, man, this, I'm excited about this.
Look how good this looks!
I'm an absolute genius.
This is so good.
Mm.
Oh, man!
Jimmy, put this on the menu.
Put this on the menu.
One more.
I really want to keep eating this.
One more bite. I'm sorry.
Here's a US Beast-style
double burger combo.
Over here, it will run you $15.29.
That same combo in the UK is £14.99.
Yes.
Leon's having none of it.
But what about the delivery fees?
Using the MrBeast Burger site, in the US,
the same combo with tax,
delivery fees, and tip
costs $28.72,
increasing the cost by 87.8%.
Oof!
So, if possible, you may
want to go pick up your food.
It's a similar deal here in the UK.
We checked this order on Deliveroo,
and they charge a £2.49 delivery fee
and a £2.05 service charge,
which jacks the price
up by almost a third.
One big difference worth pointing out
is the tipping culture
in the UK and the US.
It's much less common to tip in the UK
than it is in America.
In the UK, if you go to a
restaurant for some food,
it's usually common to give maybe a 10%
or a 12.5% service charge if
the service has been good.
But you can even opt out of that
if you don't want to pay it.
Particularly where delivery is concerned,
I think tipping is even
less common in the UK.
I got a notification, actually,
on my Deliveroo app the other day
to say that 6% of people in my area
have been tipping their drivers recently.
So that's six out of every 100 people
are tipping a delivery driver.
When I say that we don't have as much
of a tipping culture in the UK,
it's not that we're really stingy.
We just generally have a
much higher minimum wage
in the UK than you do in the US,
so there's less reliance on tips
to make ends meet for
service-industry staff.
We thought we'd take a look back over
the story of MrBeast Burger
to give you all some context.
It all started with a
YouTube video back in 2020,
in which MrBeast opened a
single drive-through restaurant
where the food is free,
and customers would even
get free money for visiting.
Obviously thousands of people showed up,
and the video got over 100 million views.
At the end of the video, MrBeast announced
MrBeast Burger, his chain of burgers,
which was available across
the US for delivery.
He partnered with Virtual Dining Concepts,
a platform which matches brands
with existing restaurants
and kitchens to prepare and deliver food.
By using existing kitchens,
MrBeast Burger was able to expand rapidly,
opening 300 locations in
the US in the first week,
followed by more in the UK
and Canada shortly after.
For context, it took McDonald's six years
to open 300 US locations.
You can start to see why
brands love virtual kitchens.
At the time of filming
this, there is only one
brick-and-mortar MrBeast Burger location,
recently opened in New
Jersey's American Dream mall.
At the grand opening, over
100,000 fans showed up,
some waiting in line all night.
It was a massive success,
captured by Colin and Samir,
who documented the entire day.
According to the doc,
at the grand opening,
MrBeast Burger sold 6,212 burgers
and broke the world record by three times.
Guinness World Records has asked for proof
and at the time of this recording
has not made it official.
But it hasn't all been sunshine and roses.
Pretty much anybody can apply
to become a virtual
kitchen for MrBeast Burger.
There's a form on the Virtual
Dining Concepts website
where you can tell them
which facilities you have in the kitchen.
So if you have a fryer,
a flattop, and a fridge
and you normally make fried food,
even if you just have a single location,
you can cook MrBeast Burger.
That's all it takes.
A fryer, a flattop, and a fridge.
I mean, you can buy a
deep-fryer for pretty cheap,
and I feel like you could
install a flattop on
pretty much any kitchen, and
everyone's got a fridge, so,
I feel like I could probably cook
MrBeast Burger if I wanted to.
A wide variety of restaurants
acting as virtual kitchens
has led to a slew of quality-control
issues for the chain.
The food is coming from
all types of restaurants
independent of each other,
so what you're getting may
be a bit of a crapshoot.
So we went ahead and got MrBeast Burger
from a second location.
First, the Chandler style. [grunts]
And I have to say, it
looks pretty good, right?
Very impressed.
The Chandler style from restaurant No. 2.
OK, the first thing I noticed
is the burger's not wrapped.
Is that OK?
It's bigger.
But, I mean, that's clearly different bun.
This is more of a smash patty.
How it's really almost paper-thin,
where this just looks like tiny burgers.
Chandler burger, right?
Mm, the cheese makes this one.
No. It's a different quality of meat too.
I think that this actually
is pertinent information.
This is from a restaurant in Glendale.
This was from the Buca di
Beppo's at Universal Studios.
Hot chicken sandwich.
All right, again, place
No. 1, the place we like.
It's saying it's Nashville,
but instead of doing chicken sandwiches,
they're doing chicken-tender sandwiches.
Bit of a disparity between A and B.
Mm-hmm. Not that crispy. Spicy?
That's disappointing.
There's no spice to that.
I mean, this one.
Yeah. Mm!
That, however, is much better.
Despite some of these
quality discrepancies,
MrBeast Burger shows no sign
of slowing down its growth.
Earlier this year, MrBeast
tweeted that the brand
has already shared over
$100 million of revenue
with restaurants across America.
When he says shared, it
means that not all the money
is going to MrBeast,
nor is all the money
going to the restaurants.
The restaurants will
obviously take a large cut,
but then some of the money will go
to Virtual Dining Concepts,
and I'm sure some of it is
going to MrBeast as well.
For example, one restaurant
in Dallas, Texas, claimed
it sold $7,000 worth of MrBeast
Burgers in a single day.
MrBeast actually once described
the launch of MrBeast Burger as a gamble,
but so far it's looking
like that gamble paid off.
We actually collected
today's order in-store,
and I had to kind of place the order there
by showing the guy my phone,
and he kind of tapped
it all through for me.
He was actually kind of surprised
at how much the burgers cost.
He said they looked quite expensive.
I guess it just means that he wasn't aware
of how many fees are being added on
so that either the delivery platform
or Virtual Dining Concepts can
get a fair cut of the profit.
It seems like the nutritional
stats for MrBeast Burger
are actually the same
in the US and the UK.
A Beast style with double
patties is 950 calories,
66 grams of fat, 23
grams of saturated fat,
43 grams of carbs, 41 grams of protein,
and 1,840 milligrams of sodium.
Note that is 80% of your daily sodium.
Make it a Beast-style triple,
and the calories go up to 1,160,
which is over half of
your daily allowance.
What you really have to look out for here
is the saturated fat. A Beast-style triple
contains 150% of your
daily recommended intake.
Bump it up to a Beast-style
double burger combo
with unseasoned fries
and a can of Sierra Mist.
Gives you a grand total of 1,330 calories.
Bump it up to a triple,
and you hit 1,540 calories.
Comparing the Beast-style burger
to other fast-food-chain burgers,
MrBeast, calorie-wise, lands about here.
It's pretty high up there.
But good news for Jimmy:
No one in America cares.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
We wanted to find out all the
differences between Red Bull
in the UK and the US.
This is Food Wars.
In the UK,
Red Bull comes in three portion sizes:
A 250-milliliter can,
a 355-milliliter can,
and a 473-milliliter can.
In the US,
our Red Bull cans come in four sizes,
8.4 fluid ounces, or 250 milliliters,
12 fluid ounces, or 355 milliliters,
16 fluid ounces, or 473 milliliters.
And the biggest one,
20 fluid ounces — yo!
— or 591 milliliters.
That means our US largest size
is 30% bigger than the UK's.
Harry: Let's see if we're actually getting
our 473 milliliters' worth.
Actually, looks slightly more than 473.
Maybe we're getting
even more for our money.
The largest single item
by volume in the UK
is a 24-pack of our 355-milliliter cans.
That totals 8,520 milliliters,
which is around 288 fluid ounces.
While we do have a larger can on offer,
that only comes as part of a 12-pack,
meaning that the total is
only 5,664 milliliters,
which is less than the
24-pack of this one.
In the US, our largest
Red Bull item is a 24-pack
of 12-fluid-ounce cans.
I was unable to get my hands on it,
but it is the same liquid
amount as the UK's largest.
Our closest second is a
12-pack of 24-fluid-ounce cans.
Here are all the Red Bull
products you'll find in the UK,
some of which you won't find in the US.
Here are all the Red Bull items in the US
you won't find in the UK.
So technically we have eight
Red Bull products in the UK.
We have the normal one,
we have the sugar-free one,
we have the zero one,
red, green, yellow, orange, and white.
Some of these are seasonal
and will rotate in and out,
so it's a little bit
tricky to keep track of
exactly what's on offer,
but this is what we could get today.
In addition to this,
we have a couple of sugar-free exclusives,
which technically adds to the total.
From what I can tell,
these three flavors are
exclusive to the US,
and you can't find them in the UK.
First, we have the blue edition,
which is blueberry flavored,
and we got the peach flavored,
which I believe is flavored peach,
and the winter edition,
which is what flavor?
Fig apple? Hmm.
Now both countries have
the coconut flavor,
but from what I can tell online,
we also have the coconut
sugar-free flavor.
I actually couldn't even
find sugar-free versions
of the red one or the orange one.
I did find a sugar-free
yellow one, though.
You can tell it's sugar-free
because it's got this blue
sugar-free band there,
blue sugar-free label there,
and also the tab is blue.
That's quite fun.
While it's not technically a UK exclusive,
I did find this one while
I was hunting for Red Bull,
I think it's imported from Thailand,
and it's a
cold-brew-coffee-flavored Red Bull,
which sounds pretty intense.
Because there aren't too many exclusives
between the US and the UK,
I'm going to do a lightning round
of every flavor I can get
my hands on here in the US.
Couldn't find any of
the sugar-free options,
but I know they are available,
at least online,
and also I got Red Bull Zero
and sugar-free Red Bull.
So let's do a quick lightning
round of each flavor.
Ready?
The issue here is that I
don't drink energy drinks.
I don't like the taste of Red Bull.
They make me feel weird.
I drink tea if I need a bit of
a caffeine hit, and that's it.
But apparently I have to
taste-test all of these,
so wish me luck.
I am not happy about this.
Regular Red Bull flavors, but sugar-free.
I don't think I've ever
had a sugar-free one.
Maybe I should.
because I did drink an
alarming amount of Red Bull
when I was younger,
and maybe a sugar-free option
would've been a good idea.
You know.
A little side-by-side action.
Regular,
sugar-free.
I might still be getting
the sugar-free ones.
It's, like, really close.
Good job on that, Red Bull.
Basically the only time I drink Red Bull
is when it's in a Jagerbomb.
It's also makes me think of those,
which is not the vibe for
an 11 a.m. video shoot.
Cheers, I guess.
So this is the normal Red Bull.
Yeah.
The best thing I can
say about this is that
the taste kind of, like,
disappears fairly fast.
So I'll
leave that in the middle to begin with
while I do the rankings.
This is the sugar-free version
in the giant can.
The aftertaste isn't quite as nice
with the sugar-free version.
Slightly worse than the regular one.
Sugar-free has some sugar in it, I guess.
It says zero grams of
sugar and sugar-free,
but for some reason, they got another one
that's zero sugar.
OK.
Doesn't have much of a
taste either, to be honest.
You get that, kind of
like that energy drink
jolt you get when you take
a sip of an energy drink.
The Red Bull Zero oddly doesn't have that.
OK, the coconut edition,
coconut berry Red Bull.
I've never seen a human
being drink any of these.
Never in my life have I seen
anyone purchase one of these
or drink them.
Up until me making this video,
I did not know these existed,
and I don't know why they exist still.
Let's find out. All right,
coconut and berry Red Bull.
The product nobody asked for.
This coconut berry Red Bull
is absolutely terrible.
That is what it's like to drink, uh,
sunscreen?
Red one. Watermelon.
I actually don't hate that.
That's not bad.
My issue is I don't
understand why they settled on
that as the taste of like,
unsweetened, unflavored Red Bull.
Because it's not good.
At least in my opinion,
watermelon has helped that out.
The green edition, the dragon fruit.
As you are aware, dragons are green,
so clearly the can is green dragon fruit.
Everyone make that connection?
Oh, my God.
It's somehow worse than this one.
It's somehow worse.
This is what I think pee tastes like.
Does that make sense?
It smells like pee.
The energy that Red Bull gives you
is being counteracted by
the absolute depression
these flavors are giving me right now.
I'm, like, having this weird
thing of all this energy,
and it's being converted into
sadness because of these two.
Next up is the green one,
which is flavored with cactus fruit.
I don't know what cactus
fruit is meant to taste like.
If I saw a green can,
I would assume maybe green apple or lime.
It's fine.
I don't think it's quite
as good as the watermelon.
Ah, watermelon Red Bull.
Ugh, I don't want to do this anymore.
We're making a comeback.
Watermelon's not bad.
Oh yeah, baby.
The Red Bull meter is going up.
Sugar-free tropical fruits.
I generally quite like tropical
fruits-flavored things,
because I have a palate of a child.
I spoke too soon.
That's really gross.
No. Bad. Worst one so far.
Worse than the sugar-free normal one.
All right, blue edition blueberry.
Yeah, not bad. Tart.
Wow, tart.
Thirty-eight grams of sugar in this.
You would not think. You
would not believe that
from the way this tastes.
I guess I'm not complaining.
It's just, do you want your
energy drink to be tart?
Regular tropical fruits.
One thing I'm already noticing
is that the sugar-free versions
have much less of a strong smell
compared to the versions with sugar.
It's better than the sugar-free version.
Still not great.
Try that one more time.
The regular tropical
version is actually better
than unflavored Red Bull.
Whereas the sugar-free one,
something's gone wrong there,
cause that is actually worse
than the classic Red Bull.
All right. Peach edition.
Peach nectarine.
Yeah, here we go.
Mmm, yeah, wow.
Ooh, that's good.
That's really good.
Also tart. Thirty-eight grams of sugar.
The summer edition apricot strawberry.
I mean, that sounds lovely.
This maybe sounds like the most appealing
of any of them so far.
So I've got high hopes.
Smells pretty good.
I get notes of strawberry.
Oooh. Oooh, OK.
See, this is concerning,
because I didn't actually
want to like any of these.
This is a problem, guys.
I can't become a Red Bull guy.
I'm not ready for a Red Bull era.
I'm too loyal to Mercedes.
This is pretty good.
I definitely, like,
I get apricot and strawberry from that.
It's not overpowering.
It's just like a sort
of nice spark of very —
yeah, that's the best
one I've tried so far.
Winter edition.
Fig apple.
Fig apple, winter.
I'm not making the connection.
Um.
Not good. It tastes like if
a sour apple Jolly Rancher was a drink.
Does that make sense?
No, not refreshing at all.
The coconut and berry edition,
I'm not getting much, if any,
of the berry flavor from this.
Coconut's definitely the
the star of the show,
but it's not bad coming
from someone who, say,
doesn't usually like
coconut as a flavoring.
I think it's actually, it's
better than the tropical,
as far as I'm concerned.
And last on the flavor train
we got the yellow edition tropical.
Ooh, tropical.
Oh, it doesn't smell very good.
Just please be at least OK.
Oh I can.
Yeah. OK.
Yeah, it's all right. OK.
And then last, but by no means least,
we have this random imported
coffee one that I found.
My only concern, or I guess
comment, on this one is that
I'm not sure who the target audience is.
Because I feel like if you like coffee,
you'll just drink coffee
if you want a caffeine hit.
I'm not sure why, if you liked coffee,
you would want to flavor
your Red Bull with coffee,
because you're already
getting the caffeine.
But here you're just
getting, like, loads of sugar
and additives as well.
It tastes like someone has taken a coffee
and poured Coca-Cola in it.
Which might be to your liking.
Joe: Hits the spot. The "I
want to jack my caffeine lover
through the roof" spot.
I, actually, where would that go?
Is that better than regular Red Bull?
I actually don't think it is.
But is it the worst one I've had today?
No. No, it's not.
That's there.
That's there, and we're done.
My vision is starting to blur.
Ooh, this might have been a bad idea.
Oh no, no, it's kicking in.
I like Red Bull.
Sugar-free is exactly the same thing.
This one had less of an aftertaste,
which actually, I didn't really like.
Coconut and dragon fruit.
Suntan lotion and pee.
Watermelon, I liked.
Blue, a little too tart.
Peach, I enjoyed.
Fig apple, trash.
And tropical, not bad.
My main takeaways from that,
firstly, I need to lie down.
If we can make that happen,
that would be great.
Secondly, I think the sugar-free
versions are overwhelmingly
worse-tasting than the sugar versions are.
I also think for me, like I say,
I don't love the taste
of just normal Red Bull,
so I think I've ended up liking the ones
which are flavored with
things which aren't Red Bull.
So that makes sense.
What about the price?
Well, in the UK, a 250-milliliter can
will cost you 1.50 pounds
at a Tesco supermarket.
That works out to roughly 60
pence per 100 milliliters,
which is around 74 cents.
In the US,
The cost of this
250-milliliter Red Bull can
at Walmart is $2.18,
which breaks it down to 80
cents per 100 milliliters.
So it looks like the UK
is actually getting a slightly better deal
on its Red Bull than the US is.
That's actually kind of a Food Wars first,
so it doesn't happen often.
In the UK, our standard Red Bull
contains the following ingredients:
water, sucrose, glucose,
acidifier citric acid,
taurine, sodium carbonates
and magnesium carbonate, caffeine,
niacin, pantothenic acid,
vitamin B6, vitamin
B12 flavorings, colors,
caramel and riboflavin,
and carbon dioxide.
Our Red Bull in the US
contains pretty much
the same stuff.
Carbonated water, sucrose,
glucose, citric acid, taurine,
sodium bicarbonate, magnesium
carbonate, caffeine.
Niacinamide.
Calcium pantothenate.
Pyridoxine HCI.
Vitamin B12, natural
and artificial flavors.
All right.
The vitamins have different
names, but it's all the same.
You may notice the ingredient
taurine on that list.
Now, taurine has been the subject of
inaccurate rumors on
the internet for years.
Taurine has an association with bulls,
drawing its name from the
Latin word for bull, taurus.
Some people run with this
and falsely claim that
it's code for bull semen.
The name actually comes from the fact that
taurine was first isolated from ox bile.
OK, the good news is that
there's no ox spit in Red Bull,
as food producers have used a
synthetic version of taurine
that isn't derived from animals.
It also means that Red Bull
is suitable for vegans.
One study found that exposing
human teeth to energy drinks
for 15 minutes, four times a day,
resulted in a significant
and irreversible loss of tooth enamel.
The study also noted that
energy drinks were twice as
harmful as regular soft drinks
to tooth enamel.
As the study in rats found,
chronic intake of Red
Bull may cause a decline
in kidney function.
However, these results
have not been replicated
in human studies.
But any excuse to see my
boys, the dancing rats.
Red Bull in the UK contains 110 calories
per 250-milliliter can.
One of these cans also
contains 27 grams of sugar.
According to their website,
this is actually a similar amount of sugar
to what you might find
in say, apple juice.
Both sugar-free Red Bull and Red Bull Zero
contain 10 calories per
this 8.4-fluid-ounce can.
Sugar-free replace their sugar with
acesulfame potassium and aspartame.
Red Bull Zero replaced sugar with
acesulfame potassium K and sucralose.
Acesulfame potassium, or Ace K,
which is Red Bull's
zero-calorie sweetener,
has had its share of
controversy over the years.
Although, to be fair,
a lot of the studies this came
from were done in the 1970s.
This has led to the validity
being called into question
in recent years.
According to Healthline.com,
in 1996, the Center for
Science in the Public Interest
urged the FDA to do more testing on Ace K
before allowing its
inclusion in soft drinks.
The CSPI go on to say that there are
health concerns associated with a Ace K,
including cancer, hormone disruption,
and risks to pregnant people.
There's also a study that determined
the chronic use of Ace K in male mice
was linked to possible
changes in brain function
over a period of 40 weeks.
Yeah, I believe that it's been 40 minutes,
and my brain is just.
One of the perceived
benefits of drinking Red Bull
is that it's supposed
to give people a boost
through its caffeine content.
A 250-milliliter can contains
80 milligrams of caffeine.
But is that a lot?
Compared to other soft drinks?
Yeah.
A 12-ounce can of Coke contains
34 milligrams of caffeine.
That's less than half
the amount of caffeine
and almost double the amount
of fluid as this Red Bull.
A 12-ounce can of Mountain Dew
contains slightly more,
with 55 milligrams.
If we compare Red Bull to
another popular energy drink,
Monster, you'll find that
they actually have the same
caffeine content per 100 milliliters,
which is 32 milligrams.
Although Monster cans tend to be bigger,
so you are getting more caffeine in total.
The caffeine amount, however,
can be a bit underwhelming when
compared to regular coffee.
An eight-ounce, 237-milligram
brewed coffee contains on average
95 milligrams of caffeine,
and a double shot of espresso
contains 125 milligrams.
One issue comes from the fact that
some people will consider Red
Bull to be more like a soda,
and therefore might drink
higher quantities of it.
So is it possible to overdose on Red Bull?
Yeah, although highly unlikely.
Caffeine-related deaths have
been found in individuals
that intake somewhere
between 3 and 5 grams —
not milligrams, grams —
of caffeine in one day.
That would be 40 of these.
I feel like your bladder
would explode first.
Although apparently, that
wasn't enough caffeine
for some people.
In 2014, Red Bull was sued
in a class-action lawsuit
around false advertising.
Remember the ad campaign
"Red Bull gives you wings"?
Well, it doesn't.
False advertising.
Back then, Red Bull did
say in its marketing
that this drink could
improve concentration
and reaction speeds,
a claim that lacked
any scientific support.
Furthermore, the suit said that Red Bull
persistently and pervasively
market their product
as a superior source of energy,
worthy of a premium price
over a cup of coffee or
other sources of caffeine.
Red Bull did agree to a
$13 million settlement,
which granted anyone
who purchased a Red Bull
dating back the January 1, 2002,
was entitled to $10 or
$15 worth of Red Bull.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between movie-theater food at
AMC and Odeon movie theaters
in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
It might seem like Odeon and
AMC are different chains.
However, they're actually
owned by the same company,
so let's compare.
Popcorn in a UK Odeon
cinema comes in four sizes.
There's a kids, regular,
medium, and large.
Classic popcorn at a US
AMC comes in three sizes,
small, regular, large,
and of course, if you want
to get a to-go option,
they have the AMC megabag.
Boom!
That's three times the
size of the standard large.
Harry: Let's weigh a large salted popcorn
in both countries to see
whose large is bigger.
So, our large salt popcorn is actually,
I think comes to 204 grams,
which is about 30 grams more
than we were supposed to get.
Joe: 194 grams of popcorn.
"Avatar." Haven't seen it.
And for my own morbid curiosity,
so, I'm going to weigh it in the bag.
I don't know, just
subtract, like, 2 grams.
How much could the bag weigh?
This.
620 grams.
Drinks at a US AMC theater
come in three sizes.
Small, 20 fluid ounces;
regular, 32 fluid ounces;
and a large "Avatar," 44 fluid ounces.
Harry: Now, shockingly,
our drinks in the UK
are actually just as big
as the US ones for once.
Cinemas I think are the
only place in the UK
where you can get a drink of this size.
The thought of getting one of
these from a fast-food place
in the UK is absolutely unheard of.
Let's measure out the
large in both countries
to see if we're getting as
much as we've been promised.
Joe: Wow, it's pretty close.
What was it supposed to be? 44?
By my calculations,
they've pretty much nailed
bang on the 40-ounce line,
so you're maybe not getting quite as much
as you were promised.
Admittedly, we did lose
a little bit in transit
and also a little splash
just on the table there,
so maybe you could round it up
generously to, like, 41, 42,
which, honestly, even
if it's slightly less
than you're being promised,
I think we can forgive them.
Certainly we can't fault
James Cameron for this.
Certainly we can't blame
the Na'vi of Pandora.
We also have ice drinks,
which are the iconic Tango ice blasts.
We have them in three sizes,
a regular, a medium, and a large.
Tango ice blasts are amazing.
They have a bit of a
cult following in the UK.
I think cinemagoers over here
really, really love these.
You can get them usually in two flavors,
which are red and blue.
I don't know exactly what
they're supposed to taste of.
It's kind of just tangy
food coloring anyway.
They're not supposed to look like this.
As you can probably tell,
these have just been sat out
under the studio lights for a while.
Here's what they're supposed to look like.
You can also get ice
beverages at the US AMC,
primarily in the form of an Icee,
and they come in three sizes normally,
but not the AMC we went to.
They only had regular.
It should be a small, 20-fluid-ounce.
The regular "Avatar: Way of the Water"
Na'vi-colored drink here
is a 32-fluid-ounce,
and of course the large
is a 44-fluid-ounce.
I think that's the exact same size
as the soft drinks we just had.
I would like to request,
I don't know how hard this is going to be,
if Yuelei and the rest of
the postproduction team
can make it look like I'm
in the underwater "Avatar."
With me just swimming
with the Na'vi? Right?
Whee, I'm in the movie!
How hard would that be?
Can you make it 3D as well?
That's pretty easy, right?
Can you have that done
by end of day Friday?
When I'm swimming
around with Jake Sully.
Here is everything you'll
find at a UK Odeon cinema
that you won't find in an AMC.
Here's everything at a US AMC
you won't find at an Odeon.
We'll start with the
classic, which is popcorn.
In the UK, it comes in two
flavors, as salted or sweet.
You can also ask them to
mix them together for you.
Salt and sweet, excellent contrast.
You won't find butter popcorn
anywhere on the menu in the UK.
The fact that you guys are
putting melted butter on popcorn,
extremely weird to us. Stop doing that.
In the US, our popcorn
obviously comes plain or salted,
but we also have butter popcorn,
and yes, Harry,
we like to put melted
butter all over our popcorn.
Two things I want to know.
One, it's almost always referred to as
"butter-flavored topping,"
presumably because they
can't legally call it butter,
or maybe there's just other junk in there
and it isn't officially butter.
In America there's just some people
who are so nuts about the butter.
AMC now has something -- I
don't know if this is to go
or you get this in the theater
-- where they give you,
no joke, this thing of butter on the side
to take into the theater with you,
because there's so much
butter-flavor-topping drama in the US,
AMC was like, here, just take
this and go do it yourself.
Oh.
Wow, look at that. You
see that? You see that?
Oh, yeah.
I want you to pay attention.
Now, imagine I'm eating this in the dark.
"Ooh, I like my butter so much. Mwah."
Look at this! Look at my hands!
This is the messiest snack in the world.
I never get butter on my
popcorn. This is so gross.
Yeah, it doesn't actually
taste that much like butter.
It has a buttery flavor to it.
Yeah, it's definitely flavored butter.
That's not melted butter.
You can also get sweets
as a topping on your popcorn in the UK.
This comes in the form of
Cadbury's Dairy Milk buttons,
as Smarties, Kit Kats, and Rolos.
Speaking of popcorn,
you can also get cheddar
popcorn, which is,
I don't know if this is
just not in your theaters
or really popular in the UK at all,
but it's popcorn that is
tossed in cheese dust.
And also caramel corn, which is popcorn,
you guessed it,
encased in caramel.
[crunching]
There's a range of hot food
options at a UK Odeon cinema,
including the following:
Firstly, we have the
iconic cinema hot dog.
Now, obviously you guys
have hot dogs in America.
However, it's an exclusive
because ours is a pork sausage
while yours, I think, is beef.
That looks real sad.
Oh, no.
Oh, hot dog. Yay!
That's a pretty good-sized hot dog, right?
Movie-theater hot dogs for
some reason are really good.
You ever notice that? Movie
theaters and ball games,
that's where the hot
dog's the absolute best.
Next up, we have two pizza
options at UK Odeon cinemas.
You can get a cheese pizza
or a pepperoni pizza.
I haven't even opened them
and I'm losing my mind
because this is how they've been packaged
and presented to us.
What is that?
Um, I'm slightly at a loss for words.
I might be giving them
too much credit here.
I think maybe if this were
fresh out of the oven,
which obviously this is not,
it actually might be OK.
But there's a reason why pizza
boxes exist, for example.
Maybe look into that in future.
I'm just imagining any Italian viewers
watching this and just crying.
You can also get flatbread pizzas.
The AMC I went to did
not currently have them
because I went there
right when they opened.
They weren't ready yet.
But you can get also a
four-cheese, a pepperoni,
or a supreme flatbread pizza.
You can also get yourself curly fries.
Now we're talking. Curly fries, right?
Mm.
The Impossible nuggets.
[thudding]
Oh, yes.
For some reason I picked
the marinara. Let's do it.
Who doesn't want to eat
fake deep-fried meat
and dip it in a red sauce
in a pitch-dark theater?
Nope. Oh, wow.
Those are really bad.
We have pretzel bites at our AMC.
You can get them unsalted with cheese;
salted with cheese, which I got;
garlic Parmesan with cheese;
everything bagel with cheese;
and cinnamon sugar with icing.
They don't taste bad,
but they're really chewy.
You're going to want those
right out of the oven.
Or the microwave.
You can also get a
Bavarian legend pretzel.
The theater we went to did not have them
at the time of filming this.
At a UK Odeon, you can
get triple-dip nachos,
which are tortilla chips
which come with guacamole,
salsa, and I think a cheese sauce.
This is how it came.
What we have is just a bag
of plain tortilla chips
and a box labeled "dips."
We have the cheese sauce.
We have some very vibrant guacamole,
like someone blended up Shrek.
We have some tomato salsa.
Jalapeños.
I think this was onion
and chive dip, maybe.
I feel like I have to try
and assemble these somehow.
I want to do it in a way
that hopefully you guys can
join me along for the ride,
because it could be interesting.
I want to try and get some layerage going
on there if possible.
Oh, God.
Oh, no! [laughing]
OK. I thought that all
came out as one brick,
but there were actually two
pots in there. Thank God.
Go on.
Yeah, you go. Look at that queso.
OK, now we're going to
hit it with some salsa.
Personally, I think this
has gone sensationally well.
This is,
this is nachos right here.
Some people might say, "Harry,
do you want to heat these up?"
I'd say, "No. Doesn't need it.
Perfect the way they are."
Oh, man, look at the color on this.
No. My mum used to like the nachos.
She's not dead,
I just haven't been to the
cinema with her in a while.
[crew laughing]
Yeah? Yeah?
Leon: They actually don't look bad.
They don't look terrible, right?
Absolutely disgraceful.
I don't know what's going
on on that island of yours,
but your nachos, thumbs down.
I would say pretty
generous with the chips.
Not bad, right?
These are UK-level nachos right here.
I don't know who is
like, "Oh, yeah, perfect.
This is exactly what I think nachos are."
Did they make a mistake?
Am I looking at this right?
They gave us a thing of marinara sauce?
I'm assuming this marinara
was supposed to be salsa.
Can you imagine?
Because you just get this
and go to the theater,
and you're in the dark, and
you're watching a movie.
"Oh, man. Man, this salsa sure
isn't very chunky. Oh, well.
Man, I cannot wait to eat these nachos.
Oh, I'm so worried about the
tree of life, 'Avatar 2.'"
Oh, no, f---.
Like, what the hell?!
It's so bad it's, like,
oddly alluring.
Does that make sense?
This is terrible. I'm sorry.
I'm going to do everyone a
favor and throw this out.
Yuck!
Then we're on to the sides.
We have a couple of side options in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
Unfortunately, one of them
we couldn't find today,
which are crisper fries,
which are kind of like
very thin slices of potato
which are fried.
However, we could get our
hands on these chicken strips,
which are actually pretty good.
Technically also included on
the sides menu are the dips,
so that includes basically
everything that you would
normally find on the nachos,
including the side of jalapeños,
the salsa dip, the cheese, the guacamole,
and this cream cheese,
garlic, and herb dip.
We have one prepackaged-popcorn option
if you don't fancy the
fresh stuff, which is this:
Butterkist toffee popcorn.
I think this is kind
of more similar to what
you guys might expect from
caramel corn in the US.
It's basically popcorn,
but with an actual coating
of this sugary, syrupy stuff.
Now, the AMC has a bunch of snack options
that you won't find in the UK,
starting with these, known
as "lifestyle snacks."
I'm assuming they're meant
to be a little bit healthier.
Starting all the way down here,
you have the Planters
sweet and salty trail mix.
Grass-fed beef jerky,
courtesy of Country Archer.
I don't know about this.
Rhythm organic white
cheddar cauliflower bites.
No, thanks.
Homefree chocolate chip cookies.
You got only 3 grams of sugar
for these smart and
sweet watermelon bites.
Mango sweet and tangy
supersnacks. Dried mangoes.
And SkinnyDipped dark chocolate almonds.
In addition to the popcorn,
we also have some sweets and chocolates,
which I will go through now.
Wine gums. Do you guys
have wine gums in the US?
I really like these. They're
a bit of an old-person sweet.
I still don't know exactly
why they're called wine gums,
because I don't think
they have wine in them.
On top of the gummies themselves,
they will have the name of
a wine kind of stamped on,
and they're different colors.
The flavors change according to the color.
Red one's always the best, of course.
Couple of Cadbury Dairy Milk options.
We have some Cadbury
caramel Dairy Milk nibbles,
Dairy Milk giant buttons,
Galaxy minstrels.
So, in the UK we have Dairy
Milk, which is owned by Cadbury,
and then the Mars
Corporation has their own
brand of milk chocolate,
which is called Galaxy.
And this is basically Galaxy chocolate
with a hard shell on the outside.
These honestly are really good.
Cadbury twirl bites.
It's Cadbury Dairy Milk
chocolate, and it's kind of got
this weird swirled texture on the inside,
so it lends itself to being quite a flaky
and almost melt-in-your-mouth
chocolate bar.
They're pretty good.
Aero peppermint bubbles.
It's got this weird aerated
texture in the middle,
which is designed basically
to melt in your mouth when you eat it.
Milkybar buttons! I
loved Milkybar as a kid.
It's basically white chocolate,
which I used to love when I was younger.
I think as my palate has kind of evolved
as I've gotten older,
I don't really tolerate white
chocolate like I used to,
but these are great. Bit
of a nostalgia factor.
And the last one we found
today was Maltesers.
I love a Malteser.
I still don't fully understand
what they are, to be honest.
What is the middle bit?
It's not honeycomb,
but it's got a crunchy,
almost honeycomb texture.
Now, it's not a prepackaged option,
but it is a sweet option.
We have pick and mix cups in the UK.
Pick and mix is a really
iconic British thing, I think.
It's basically this notion
of, you go into a sweet shop,
or in this case a cinema,
and they'll have lots of
different pots or tubs
of individual candies,
and you can go in with a scoop,
scoop a few, put them in,
and create your own mixture of them.
So if there's one particular
one that you love,
you can just have a cupful of that,
or you can go for some variety,
mix it up a little bit,
like we've done today.
The issue is when you're layering it,
you end up just going one
layer of thing at a time.
I haven't assembled this very well.
Couldn't get everything.
Just grabbed a bunch of stuff
that I thought looked pretty good.
Also I think some classics here.
Milk Duds.
Junior Mints, the big box.
Mini Snickers. Hey.
Skittles.
My teeth are already starting to hurt.
Butterfingers unwrapped minis.
And Sour Patch Kids.
And also Airhead extremes.
This, of course, just
the tip of the iceberg.
You can get so, so many candies at AMC.
This many.
You can also get a Ben
& Jerry's milkshake.
What they do is they let you choose
three scoops of ice cream of your choosing
and then pretty much
just blend them together
to create a milkshake.
Also in the US we have ice
cream you can't get in the UK.
You can get yourself a Dibs Crunch,
a Häagen-Dazs bar almond,
a Nestlé Toll House ice cream sandwich,
and a Nestlé's Drumstick.
The other soft-drink
exclusives are actually
aimed more at children.
We have some Fruit Shoots,
which come either as this one,
which is apple and black
currant, or as orange.
It's just kind of a bottle of squash.
And for the Americans who
might not know what squash is,
does cordial help at all?
You get a concentrated juice
and then dilute it with water
to produce basically this.
The main event as far as I'm concerned
when it comes to drinks are these ones,
which are the alcoholic options.
You can get alcohol at UK cinemas.
We got a few of the things on offer today,
and these include this Rekorderlig
strawberry and lime cider.
We have a bottle of Heineken beer.
We have some wine options.
Got a little bottle of red
here. It's really cute.
It's literally just like they've taken
a full-size bottle of red
and just squished it and scaled it down.
You can also get white wine
and I think rosé wine as well.
Or, if you're in a celebratory mood,
you can get a little bottle of prosecco.
Then we have some
premixed-cocktail options.
Today we got a classic G and T
and a Jack and Coke.
What about the beverages?
In the US, we have so, so many beverages,
starting with the Coke
Freestyle, the Freestyle machine.
You've seen it before.
It has all of these flavors.
I wasn't getting one of each.
You can also get a Gold
Peak unsweetened iced tea,
which they did not have,
a Gold Peak sweet tea, which
they also did not have,
and Minute Maid orange juice
and Minute Maid apple juice.
Chocolate milk, Dasani water, Smartwater,
and a Costa coffee.
They also didn't have that.
I could really go for some coffee.
I've been told that it is interesting
that we can get Costa coffee here.
It is actually a British coffee chain,
but it was bought by Coca-Cola in 2019
for almost £4 billion
and has now begun expanding into the US.
A large salted popcorn at a UK Odeon
contains the following:
863 calories;
48.37 grams of fat,
of which 37.84 grams are saturated;
92.18 grams of carbs,
of which 5.94 grams are sugars;
and an unknown amount of sodium.
Unfortunately, the website
didn't have the sodium information.
I did reach out via
the live-chat function,
and the guy said they didn't
know what had gone on.
He was going to look into it for me,
but I did not hear back.
A regular plain popcorn
popped in canola oil
is 550 calories, 24 grams of fat,
2 grams of saturated fat, 74 carbs,
1,380 milligrams of sodium.
The same size popcorn but this
time cooked in coconut oil,
540 calories, 24 grams of fat,
17 grams of saturated fat,
74 grams of carbs,
and 1,380 milligrams of sodium.
Now, there are no stats for
the butter-flavored topping,
which is a bit concerning,
but if you add butter and
salt to pretzel bites,
it adds 100 calories and 12 grams of fat,
7 grams of saturated fat,
and 300 milligrams of sodium.
Adding that same amount of butter
to this large "Avatar:
Way of the Water" popcorn,
which is cooked in canola oil,
you get 970 calories, 51 grams of fat,
10 grams of saturated fat --
[coughs] popcorn in my throat --
117 carbs, of which 1 gram is sugars,
and 2,450 milligrams of sodium.
Same exact size of popcorn
but this time cooked in coconut oil
and the butter topping from before.
That's 960 calories,
50 grams of total fat,
35 grams of saturated fat, 117 carbs,
of which 1 gram of that is sugars,
and the sodium, 2,450 milligrams.
People of the internet,
canola oil has slightly more calories
but way less saturated fat.
Huzzah.
A large sweet popcorn in the
UK contains the following:
1,790 calories; 73.08 grams of fat,
of which 55 grams are saturated;
253 grams of carbs, of which
84.04 grams are sugars;
and, again, an unknown amount of sodium.
Mm.
Gotta watch out for the
caramel corn, Yuelei.
This caramel corn in this size bucket,
1,620 calories. 64 grams of fat.
21 of those are saturated fat.
510 grams of carbs,
and of that, 404 of those grams are sugar,
and 3,190 milligrams of sodium.
Now, the large cheddar corn, seen here,
1,620 calories,
144 total grams of fat.
21 of those are saturated.
68 grams of carbs,
and 2,470 milligrams of sodium.
Yeesh.
What about the most calorific
thing on the UK menu?
Well, that would be a large sweet popcorn
with the topping option of
Dairy Milk giant buttons.
This combination would come
to a total of 2,004 calories,
85.08 grams of fat, 62.2
grams of saturated fat,
275.8 grams of carbs,
of which 106.44 grams are sugars.
That is just over 100%
of your daily calories,
109% of your daily fat,
311% of your daily saturates,
and 212% of your daily sugar.
Jeez.
In the US, our AMC menus vary.
I did find a PDF that had a
bunch of stuff listed on here.
I don't know how common it is at AMCs,
but it is the Bavarian legend pretzel
with the cheese cup and mustard.
That pretzel and mustard
and cheese total is
1,920 calories.
One thing I wanted to point out
is that it has 7,600 milligrams of sodium.
That is 330.4%
of your daily sodium intake.
Hey. Don't eat that pretzel.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Cinnabon in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, Cinnabon's classic rolls come
in four portion sizes: as a single,
as a two-pack, as a four-pack,
and our largest size,
a six-pack.
In the US, Cinnabon classic rolls
come in three sizes: the single —
oh, my God.
I want to eat this so bad.
Then you got the four-pack,
for you and, let's be honest, just you,
and then you can get yourself a six-pack.
This has some weight to it.
Cinnabon in the US also
offers catering sizes
that you can't get in the UK.
That means we can also get
our classic Cinnabon rolls
in a nine-pack catering tray.
Put that on the screen! Oh!
That's 50% larger than
the UK's biggest pack.
Oh, amazing.
But is there a difference in the size
of the rolls themselves?
We're going to weigh a classic Cinnabon
in both countries to find out.
You can get BonBites in
the UK, but unfortunately
the store I went to didn't
have them this morning.
If you can get them, then they should come
in a pack of four.
In the US, you can get BonBites
in a pack of four, 16,
or the catering tray of 36.
This is nine times bigger
than the UK's four-pack.
[thunder rumbles]
[laughs maniacally]
Four? Get a life.
UK Cinnabons also offer MiniBons.
These come in three portion sizes:
as a single, as a six-pack,
or our largest size, as a 15-pack.
Use these as, like, a doorstop.
I think they're stale.
[box thuds]
Over here, our MiniBons come in portions
of one, nine, 15,
and, of course, we have
a catering tray of 20.
What about the drinks?
In the UK, we can get
hot drinks in two sizes:
as a regular, which is 12 fluid ounces,
or a large, which is 16 fluid ounces.
In the US, our hot beverages
come in four sizes:
small, regular, large,
and this big catering bag.
Or does it?
[whooshes]
Because they forgot those three.
The more observant among
you would've noticed
that the UK's large is
only the regular over here.
We can also get iced drinks in the UK,
but they just come in the same sizes
as our hot drinks, 12 and 16 ounces.
The sizes change a little when you choose
the iced drinks in the US.
We got the small and the regular
and the catering size.
Again, the more observant
of you would notice
that there are some beverages
missing from this cup.
"Joe must've started
drinking them earlier."
Nuh-uh. Had a major
beverage-spilling mishap
with the delivery here.
Ah, more on that later.
The final things to compare
are the toppings and sauces.
In the UK, you can get
some additional toppings,
like the cream cheese and the pecans,
and they just come in the
one size, these little cups.
In the US, we can get extra frosting
as a regular side of the
cream-cheese frosting,
I mean, a whole pint of the frosting,
a side of pecans, who cares?
Let's weigh the largest frosting side
in each country to find the difference.
[laughs] That just, like, barely moved.
So this is eight of their frostings.
Soon to be seven.
It's described as "cream cheese ambient."
Cream cheese ambient.
That sounds like a really
experimental music genre.
It's pretty cool, you probably
wouldn't have heard of it,
but yeah, no, I listen to
mostly cream cheese ambient.
Here are all the Cinnabon
items from the UK
that you won't find in the US.
Here's everything on a Cinnabon menu
you will not find in the UK.
To start off with, we
have some Bon varieties
you actually won't find in the US.
Let's start down here with ChocoBons.
So, as far as I can tell, ChocoBons are
pretty much just the standard rolls,
maybe with a little
bit of chocolate powder
sprinkled into the mix, but then also
they are covered in chocolate sauce.
Cheers.
Our next exclusive roll
is a Lotus Biscoff Bon.
Longtime viewers of
the show will know that
I don't really like Lotus Biscoff.
I didn't realize how
passionately the crew felt
about Lotus Biscoff, because
I'm now taking heat for this.
Apparently it's because
I don't like coffee
and they're really good with coffee.
I just drink tea, so
maybe it's wasted on me.
Again, look, you do you, it's fine,
just not for me. Too sweet for me.
And then finally, because
we're actually shooting this
on Valentine's Day, we can get
a limited-edition Valentine's Bon.
All of our exclusive Bons
can also be purchased
in all three forms, which
is the regular size,
the BonBites, and the MiniBons.
We actually don't have any
exclusive Bons in the US.
We can only get the classic
and caramel pecan Bons,
both of which are obviously
available in the UK.
But we do have some other
exclusives to showcase.
The first one, the churro swirls.
♪ They forgot them ♪
But here's what they look like,
and I would love to have tried them.
Now, we don't have churro swirls,
but we do have something
called Cinnachips,
which are like small, crunchy
pieces of cinnamon roll.
I'm not sure if crunchy is what I want
from my cinnamon roll.
[crunching]
They are crunchy. They weren't kidding.
These aren't doing it for me.
They're really kind of dry and
a little bit burned, almost,
so you kind of get that,
like, acrid burn taste,
which cancels out pretty much any benefits
that you get from the cinnamon sugar.
[crunches loudly]
We also have something
called Center of the Roll,
which Cinnabon has trademarked in the US.
Now, here's what I'm assuming this is
by looking at it.
What it looks like,
they just took Cinnabons
and, like, mashed them up
or, like, unraveled them
and put them in a cup, and this is smart,
'cause the only thing I
think keeping everyone
from getting a Cinnabon at the mall
is it's kind of a pain in the butt to eat,
and I think Cinnabon noticed this,
and they responded with this.
Like, "You're right. We'll just rip it up,
put it in a cup, and have at it."
This works.
Well, you don't want to
mess with the classics.
If you want to
sit down, have a Cinnabon
at the food court,
go for it, but
if you're not in the mood,
just get one of these.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God, look at this.
Are kidding me with this?
This is so great.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I forgot —
oh, I forgot I'm shooting
a video right now.
This is the, that was the regular,
and this is the caramel pecan Bon.
We have a near equivalent here,
but we call it Roll-on-the-Go.
As far as I can tell, it's
pretty much just the same thing.
It's a small cup of I think
just the center pieces of cinnamon rolls.
Ours come in two flavors,
classic or choco.
I do think my favorite
part of a cinnamon roll
is the gooey middle bit.
See if this holds up.
This is pretty good.
Decent amount of frosting.
They could maybe have given
you slightly more frosting,
'cause I think there's some
drier bites in the middle. But.
Pretty good.
In the US, we also have cookie BonBites.
These are chocolate chip cookies
with cinnamon rolls inside of —
I'm just finding this out right now.
Chocolate chip cookies with
cinnamon rolls inside of them?
Yo, straight up when I saw this, I'm like,
who's getting cookies at Cinnabon?
This cannot have a cinnamon roll inside.
Oh, my God, do you see it?
It actually — what?
I didn't even know this existed!
You got that? You got that, yeah?
Yo, look at that, oh.
Look what's inside of it.
Oh, my God, that's crazy.
This cookie's pregnant with a Cinnabon.
[baby cries]
Now let's get in here.
Eh, better an idea than execution.
We also have CinnaSweeties,
which look like mini
doughnuts that I'm assuming
are cinnamon — oh, wait,
I think these have the frosting inside.
We've done these for ... Taco Bell?
The Cinnabon Delights. I'm pretty sure
this is filled with some sort
of, like, cream cheese, right?
Wait a second!
There's no --
[gasping]
There's no cream cheese
in these! They're blanks!
The UK Cinnabon website also advertises
that some of their branches will have
Carvel brand ice cream as an option,
but unfortunately, we didn't have that
at the one we went to.
Now we're on to the sauces and toppings.
In the US, we have a side of Oreo pieces
that you can get on top
of your Bon. There it is.
We also have the 8 ounces of frosting,
and we also have — grr, close.
This right here is,
you get a side of the caramel frosting.
That's also really good.
We only have the one
exclusive topping option here
in the UK, and it's this
one, the Lotus Biscoff crumb.
In the interest of fairness,
I'm going to try it again.
It's just fine. It's just fine.
Maybe with a coffee, but.
No, it's still not for me. Sorry, guys.
Next up, we got drinks.
Ah, finally. I'm dying of thirst.
We have coffee, obviously,
and you can also get
yourself a hot chocolate.
Let's check out their hot chocolate.
I mean, it looks like hot chocolate.
There's nothing to see.
Wow, actually not that good.
Blech.
Skip that.
We actually have a better
range of hot drinks in the UK,
including pretty much a full
range of espresso drinks,
including an Americano, a cappuccino,
a latte, a mocha, and so on.
We can also get a tea and a hot chocolate.
You can also customize the hot drinks
with a range of syrups,
including cinnamon spice,
toasted marshmallow,
salted caramel, and more,
although if you put any
of those in a cup of tea,
I will fight you. [boxing bell rings]
In the US, we have way more
cold drink options than hot.
Here are the following
exclusive cold drink options.
First up, cinnamon roll
cold brew iced coffee.
Another victim of the Uber driver.
Ooh! [laughs]
I'm falling apart.
Pretty good. Too sweet.
Then we got the raspberry lemonade.
Also missing 2 inches. Ubefied.
I mean, I don't want to
give the guy a bad rating,
but, like, look, I have
not sipped any of these.
Oh, my God, this raspberry,
I love it. It's great.
Shout-out to Greta Thunberg.
I'm gonna use my straw twice.
I care about the environment!
No more single-use plastic.
This is the frozen raspberry lemonade.
Whoa!
That's, like, powerful.
This is really good.
Bottle of milk.
No, thanks.
And, of course, fountain drinks,
and I'm the most bummed because
out of all the drinks that spilled —
we have so many flavors to choose from.
Let's get those on the screen.
But the one I specifically
wanted was this one,
was the Pibb Xtra.
Pibb Xtra's perfectly fine.
It's a Dr Pepper wannabe.
Back in the '90s, '97, '98, or whatever,
Mr. Pibb changed its formula to Pibb Xtra.
They're trying to get in on
Dr Pepper's market share.
It's so annoying. But the problem is,
is that there's no Mr. Pibb
anymore. [rousing music]
30 years of no Mr. Pibb. It's ridiculous!
I am using my platform right now
to talk to the executives
at Pibb Xtra or Mr. Pibb:
Release the Mr. Pibb recipe.
I'm begging you.
It doesn't have any value for you!
You're not making it, so
there's no value, right?
You're just sitting on the recipe,
you're not even making it?
It's worthless to you.
It's priceless to me.
And I don't want you people watching,
this happened last time,
people were messaging me like,
"Oh, yeah, we got Mr.
Pibb here at the Walmart."
It's like, it's Pibb
Xtra, it's not Mr. Pibb.
They're different. OK?
If anyone watching has cans
of Mr. Pibb from the '90s,
connect with me. I will buy it off of you.
I will pay for the shipping.
That stays in the video, or I quit.
We have a few exclusive cold
drinks over here in the UK,
including an iced latte,
a strawberry lemonade,
and a mango lemonade.
I got the strawberry lemonade today.
Pretty pleasant. Quite refreshing.
Also, in the UK, is it true that you guys
consider lemonade to be more like
a carbonated lemon beverage, like Sprite?
That's true, Joe. If you ask
for a lemonade in the UK,
expect something that's
carbonated and usually clear,
so more like a Sprite.
Although I will say,
Cinnabon seems to be doing it
kind of the American way,
so maybe you'd approve of that one.
Now, you can also get
something called a Chillatta
in the US and the UK.
However, over here, they come in flavors
of Oreo cookies and cream,
strawberries and cream,
which I got, and the
double chocolate mocha.
That's just OK.
Don't bother.
In the UK, Chillattas
come in five flavors:
cinnamon roll, strawberry, mango,
caramel latte, and chocolate mocha.
I got the cinnamon roll one today.
Actually looks pretty good.
It also looked even more impressive
when the whipped cream was
kind of in a nice swirl.
It's just, like, a,
again, quite sweet
but pretty, like, luxurious
cinnamony milkshake.
It certainly seems like it.
I cannot remember a time
when there wasn't one
in any mall I've gone to.
You can always smell it before you see it.
It's impossible to separate
the scent of Cinnabon
from the mall and vice versa.
It's like a soundtrack to the memory,
but how it smells,
so Cinnabon is like the
smell-track to malls.
Does that make sense?
And that's by design.
Cinnabon purposely put their locations
away from food courts
and other food stalls
so the Cinnabon odor would waft
and not interfere with any other smells.
So if you're in the
mall, you smell Cinnabon
and only Cinnabon, and that's
almost like nose marketing?
I don't know how you would describe it,
and it's really smart, right?
'Cause when you smell
it, man, you smell it,
and you're like, there it
is, I gotta have one. So.
Is Cinnabon a meal, a snack, a dessert?
I'm gonna go with snack.
I feel like one of
those regular Cinnabons,
I could just eat one of those
easily. Maybe one and a half.
I don't really know my Cinnabon limit.
I just kind of found out
about these little guys,
and I feel like I could easily
knock out half this tray.
I don't think it should be a meal,
'cause that could do
some damage to your body.
As far as a dessert, it seems weird to me
to eat a full meal and
then get a Cinnabon.
Like, it just kind of exists on its own.
So, yeah, it's weird
to consider it a snack,
but you're definitely
not having it for lunch,
and you're definitely not
having it after a meal, so.
By default, snack.
In the UK, a single Cinnabon classic roll
will cost you £2.99,
which at the time of
recording this was $3.65.
In the US, a single Cinnabon classic roll
will cost you $7.19.
That makes this single US roll
97% more expensive.
That is hilarious.
But does the price change if you bulk-buy?
A six-pack of classic rolls in the UK
will cost you £10.49,
which at the time of recording was $12.80.
So by spending three and a
half times the amount of money,
you're getting six times
the amount of Cinnabon,
which is a pretty good deal.
In the US, a six-pack of
Cinnabon classic rolls
will cost you $24.99,
so even when you are bulk-buying,
it's 95% more expensive to buy in the US.
For that same 500% increase in food,
we pay 247% more money.
It's not often on "Food
Wars" that it's much cheaper
in the UK than it is in
the US to buy fast food.
How's that feel, Joe?
Well, it's Cinnabon, and I
will pay whatever it takes.
This stuff is amazing.
They could double the
price. I'm still eating it.
The UK Cinnabon website doesn't give
a full nutritional
breakdown including things
like the fat and the
sugar content of Cinnabon.
However, when we got this CinnaPack,
I noticed that they actually have
a full breakdown on the box.
Here, we're given the information
for 100 grams' worth of
classic Cinnabon rolls.
So you might remember from earlier,
when we weighed one roll,
we found that it was pretty
much exactly 200 grams,
so doubling those numbers
gives us the stats
for a full roll in the UK.
Here's everything that's
in a classic Cinnabon roll
in the UK.
So that's almost 40% of your
daily recommended calories,
80% of your daily saturated fat,
and over 110% of your daily sugar.
To put the calories into context,
one of these rolls is like eating
three McDonald's hamburgers.
Here's everything in a classic
Cinnabon roll in the US.
You are reading that right,
61 grams of sugar.
And for some reason,
1,150 milligrams of sodium?
That puts us slightly ahead of the UK
in every single category.
I mean, look at that sodium.
That is way higher, for some reason.
That's exactly 50% of your
daily sodium in one roll.
What about some other even
more unhealthy menu items?
The most-calorific roll in the UK
is the Lotus Biscoff roll,
which clocks in at 1,019 calories.
That's a hefty increase
on the standard roll
as well as being over half of
your daily caloric allowance,
or, as we now use to quantify things,
four McDonald's hamburgers.
The least-healthy roll in the US
is the caramel pecan Bon,
which is 1,090 calories.
This is also the most calorific thing
on the entire US menu, sort of.
A single caramel pecan Bon roll
is 1,090 calories, but
according to Cinnabon,
if you get them in a pack of four or six,
the calories of each individual roll
increases to 1,160.
It is unclear why that is the case,
but I'm going to go ahead and guess
because they dump way more frosting on it.
The most-calorific thing on the UK menu
actually isn't a roll, it's this,
a 16-ounce cinnamon roll Chillatta.
One of these contains a
whopping 1,231 calories.
That means that one of these
large cinnamon roll Chillattas
combined with one of our
classic cinnamon rolls in the UK
would put you pretty much exactly
at your 2,000-calorie daily limit.
Cinnabon does not disclose
a full ingredients list
in the US, only allergens.
The website in the UK also didn't contain
ingredients information, but once again,
the box provided us with
all of the ingredients
of a classic cinnamon
roll, and it is a lot.
But are there any ingredients which
you need to look out for?
The bun itself is pretty much fine,
despite the sheer number of ingredients.
The things to watch out
for are actually found
in the frosting.
The frosting contains an
imitation vanilla extract,
which in turn contains E1520.
This is also known as propylene glycol.
It's fairly common in foods
and in small doses is used as a carrier
for ingredients which
aren't soluble in water.
However, it can be toxic in large doses.
It's one of the main
ingredients in antifreeze,
as it lowers the freezing point of water.
Too much propylene glycol could lead
to internal bleeding and kidney failure.
Mm. The good news is that you're unlikely
to ever hit these levels from food.
Just don't go drinking antifreeze.
The lemon extract in the
frosting also contains E102,
sometimes known as yellow 5 or tartrazine.
It's a somewhat controversial
yellow food dye.
It was part of a panic in
the UK about food colorings
causing hyperactivity in children,
although eventually it was shown
that there was limited evidence for this.
A 2015 study also found that yellow No. 5
can damage your white
blood cells, which, mm,
means you're likely to
develop tumors and cancer.
See us out, dancing rats.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Little Caesars
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Little Caesars in the US
sells Hot-N-Ready pizzas
in one size, 14 inches.
Closer to 13 ½. I'll let it slide, though.
In the UK, Little Caesars
Hot-N-Ready pizzas
only come in one size, 12 inches.
That means that the surface area
of a UK Little Caesars pizza
is 113.1 square inches.
The surface area of a
US Little Caesars pizza
is 153.94 square inches.
That makes the pizza 36%
larger than the UK's.
Now, we can get Crazy Bread in the UK,
and we ordered it from our Little Caesars,
but unfortunately they forgot it.
If they remember your Crazy Bread,
it looks like you get
four pieces with an order,
according to the website.
Too bad for the UK, but the US,
we did get our Crazy Bread,
and an order of Crazy Bread
comes with eight sticks.
Eight crazy sticks.
It wouldn't, of course,
be a order of Crazy Bread
without the Crazy Sauce.
To add insult to injury,
they gave us just the Crazy
Sauce, but without the bread.
Let's weight it anyway
to see how much we get.
A side of Crazy Sauce in
the UK weighs 7 grams.
Joe: It's 159 grams.
Whoa, it's so crazy!
No. It's not, of course. It's fine.
I wouldn't call the sauce crazy.
Misunderstood, maybe, but it feels like
the sauce kind of has it under control.
This is a very mild-mannered,
well-thought-out, well-measured sauce.
Another item available in both
countries is cheese bread.
I'll say on the
medium-rare side of cooked.
7.5 inches across, and 5.5 inches wide.
I would like to note that in the US,
our cheese bread is called
Italian cheese bread.
Ooh, that's almost exactly 9 inches.
7 inches.
If you want to get a small
pizza at a Little Caesars,
just get the Italian cheese
bread and a side of sauce.
Some assembly required.
Here are all the Little
Caesars menu items in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
Here is all of the
Little Caesars menu items
you can get in the US that
you won't find in the UK.
Before we talk about some of
the default pizza options,
we'll talk about some of
the customization options
you get in the UK that you
guys can't change in the US.
For example, over here we can
sub out the tomato sauce base
for barbecue sauce or peri-peri sauce.
I think the peri-peri
sauce is kind of a nod
to the UK's obsession with peri-peri.
You guys know how much
we love our Nando's.
I think Little Caesars are
trying to get in on that as well.
Nando's just dropped to
their knees in Tesco,
just like, oh, my God, no.
The peri-peri option doesn't stop there,
because you can also
add peri-peri seasoning
to the crust of your
pizza at Little Caesars.
The US customizations.
For the crust, round,
which I guess is regular.
But we also have thin
crust, stuffed crust,
Detroit-style deep dish,
and stuffed-crust deep dish.
For bake, we also do a well done.
Cheese, you can get,
obviously regular cheese,
but no cheese or light cheese.
Sauce, same thing, light,
normal, extra, no sauce.
Now let's talk about some of
the pizza options in the UK
you won't find on the menu in the US.
Here we have the barbecue chicken pizza.
If you stare at this thing for too long,
you will be lured into a hypnotic trance.
The barbecue sauce is very sweet
and kind of becomes the main
thing that you can taste.
If that's your thing,
do it. Not really mine.
Over this way, we have
the spicy peri-peri.
The peri-peri is quite gentle.
Just, like, a little bit of heat, maybe.
But to call that a spicy peri-peri,
I think they've oversold the spicy,
and they've also kind of
oversold the peri-peri.
Our next pizza is this one.
It's called the quattro.
What they've done is take a pizza
and divide it into fours and
then top those individually.
So you have two slices of Margherita,
two slices of pepperoni, two
slices chicken and mushroom,
and two slices of peppers,
tomatoes, and sweet corn.
All right, this says "SC pepperoni,"
stuffed-crust pepperoni.
I mean, this looks, like,
I mean, pretty generous
with the pepperoni.
It's a bit more
neon-colored than I'd like.
The crust, of course, is
stuffed with mozzarella cheese.
Eh, yeah, not bad.
Let's just try.
Sorry, stuffed crust.
People just kind of don't care about it.
Something newer to the Little
Caesars menu here in the US,
there's something called Slice-N-Stix,
which is half pizza, half breadsticks.
For the consumer who
wants a little variety,
just them by themselves don't
want to get a whole pizza
and a whole thing of sticks.
I want to point out that Slice-N-Stix
come in what I think is
this, aka the classic.
But you also get bacon Slice-N-Stix
and jalapeño Slice-N-Stix.
Throw on your grass skirts,
ladies and gentlemen.
We're going to Hawaii.
This is the Hula Hawaiian,
which of course is bacon and pineapple.
I think pineapple on
pizza's perfectly fine.
This Hawaiian's not very good, but.
The before-mentioned thin crust.
Thin-crust pepperoni.
It's pretty good, if you want
to pay the exact same price
for literally half the pizza.
So far for Little Caesars,
the pepperoni's winning across the board.
Little Caesars got me through
some financial rough patches,
so I don't want to be too hard on them.
But, I mean, I'm eating it, I'm like,
oh, yeah, my early 20s. Great.
5 Meat Feast. Count with me here.
Pepperoni, ham, sausage, hamburger?
Bacon, and, yeah, I think
it's, like, a seasoned beef.
I don't like when they go ham and pork
are two different meats. I
know they're two different,
but it's kind of like,
they're pretty close.
Or it should be five meats, two animals.
The seasoned ground beef or sausage
looks a lot like mouse turds,
making this incredibly unappetizing.
[mouse squeaks]
You're trying too hard with this one.
Then we have a few
deluxe options in the UK,
starting with a pepperoni deluxe.
If you're wondering what makes this deluxe
when compared to a standard pepperoni,
they just take some extra
pepperoni and add it to the pizza
and then sprinkle it
with Grana Padano cheese.
I will say, like, it does look
slightly more deluxe than the rest.
Let's see if it tastes deluxe.
It might just be a placebo effect,
but it does kind of taste like
the best one I've had so far.
I don't know if I'd stretch
to deluxe as an adjective,
but slightly better for sure.
Maybe just rename it the
slightly better pepperoni.
Something that here in the
US our Little Caesars has --
I've never heard of this before,
and I don't know exactly
what they're doing --
a series of pizzas, two pizzas,
called, and this is all one word,
Extramostbestest.
The Extramostbestest cheese and pepperoni.
Is this just rebranding the
plain cheese and the plain?
What makes this Extramostbestest?
All right, let's find out together.
It's an upgrade take on
their classic pepperoni pizza
that offers 80% more pepperoni,
uses 25% more cheese.
OK, so more cheese and more pepperoni.
Wait a second, wait a
second, wait a second.
Can someone grab a screenshot of that?
We'll compare this to,
there's a pepperoni that's coming up
that has a lot more on here, so.
Next up is another deluxe option.
The Margherita deluxe.
Just as a linguistic note, in the UK,
if you see a cheese-and-tomato
pizza on the menu,
it's almost always referred
to as a Margherita.
Everyone knows what that means.
It's a slightly more
traditional Italian way
of saying cheese and tomato.
Whereas in America, it seems like you guys
all just have to say cheese pizza
or you don't really understand
what you're getting.
To turn this Margherita
into a deluxe version,
it seems like all they've really done
is added, I think, some herbs
and then some chopped-up
pieces of actual tomato.
All I really have to
say about most of these
is that they're fine.
Our final deluxe pizza exclusive
is the mushroom deluxe.
Again, it looks like a fairly
standard mushroom pizza,
with, I think, the herbs again
and the Grana Padano
sprinkled around the edge.
It's also funny that they call this one
a mushroom deluxe pizza,
because there isn't actually
a standard mushroom on the menu.
So I guess if you like
mushrooms on your pizza,
you're being forced into having
the deluxe, fancy version.
This [drumroll]
is the Old World Fanceroni Pepperoni.
Guh-roan.
Now that's pepperoni! Let's go!
The cups? Oh, yeah!
Now, remember that one a
minute ago that we just saw
that was the Extrabestmostest
or whatever the hell it's called?
Yes. Yes!
Oh, they're crispy!
This is pretty good.
I will say, the dough on all these pizzas
are a lot spongier.
I'm hoping that that is a
choice to make it spongier
and not that they just
didn't cook these through.
I'll find out in a couple hours.
Of the regular round pizzas,
last and certainly least, veggie.
As before mentioned,
a version of pizza you
can get here in the US,
we have a Detroit-style deep-dish
pizza at Little Caesars.
You can get the ultimate
supreme, the veggie,
the pepperoni, the 3 Meat,
Hawaiian, and just regular cheese.
I went with the pepperoni
because I feel that's
classic Detroit style.
Hm.
Detroit, let us know in
the comments how they did.
True Detroit style puts the sauce,
or a little bit of sauce
on top. They did not.
So it just looks like
a really thick pizza.
We love our bread in this country.
I would suggest against
selling this in Detroit.
So, what we have here
is the UK-only pizza.
What we've done is take all
of the customization options
you can only find in the UK
and combine them onto one pizza.
So what this pizza has is
the peri-peri sauce base,
a barbecue sauce drizzle,
peri-peri chicken,
regular chicken, red onions,
sweet corn, and tomatoes.
Honestly, that's not terrible.
Far from the worst UK-only
creation that we've ever made.
The peri sauce base seems
to just be tomato sauce
with a bit of peri seasoning
kind of mixed into it.
So you still get a bit of
the sweetness from the tomato
and a very gentle warmth from that.
The barbecue sauce is kind
of the dominant flavor again,
but as far as UK-only
pizzas go, it's not bad.
A segment that, Yuelei,
we haven't done this in
forever, it feels like!
A USA-only! That's right!
This is a pizza you can only get
in the United States of
America at a Little Caesars.
Of all the many USA-only options,
we went with a well-done
pizza with a stuffed crust,
extra sauce, light cheese,
Old World pepperoni,
pineapple, and black olives.
Oh, man. Wah-wah.
The extra sauce I think
is what really -- oh, God.
The extra sauce is what
really ruined this,
'cause now it's just all sliding off.
Ah.
It's really bad.
And it's really bad
because it's falling apart.
And also we got this separately,
so this actually just
came out of the oven.
It's really hot.
Then we're on to the sides.
We have two exclusives in the UK.
Now, while we didn't get
any of the Crazy Bread,
at least we got the Crazy Puffs.
They take the dough,
they form it into a kind
of cupcake, muffin shape,
which is then filled
with some tomato sauce
and cheese and pepperoni.
You can see the grease,
like, dripping out of that
as soon as I bit in.
They're not bad.
They're on a mid-level of the crazy scale.
And we can also get veggie Crazy Puff.
It's the same cheese and sauce base,
but then instead of the pepperoni,
they've added corn, peppers, and onion.
We also have stuffed Crazy Bread.
Remember that Crazy Bread from earlier?
Now it's stuffed.
What the?
This is like a giant mozzarella stick.
Isn't really melted.
Oh, man, remarkably bland. Avoid.
Caesars' got wings.
Oven-roasted, barbecue, and Buffalo.
I'm starting to get a headache.
I can't for the life of me
pinpoint what is making
me suddenly so nauseous.
We have a couple of
exclusive sauces in the UK,
which means it's time for:
Sauce Talk.
We have three sauces in the UK
that you won't find on an American menu,
which is garlic and herb.
When you order at Domino's,
it comes by default
with a garlic and herb dip in the UK.
People go crazy for that
dip. People really love it.
So a few other places
have tried to kind of
jump on that bandwagon,
and this is their version.
We then have a peri-peri sauce,
and finally we have a ketchup on the menu.
I'm questioning anybody who
eats pizza with ketchup.
I'm gonna be honest.
And we don't really even have any sides
on the menu that go with ketchup, so.
The garlic and herb is defeating me.
Leon, help.
[glass breaks]
It's got quite a harsh taste, actually.
Surprisingly harsh.
Try the peri-peri.
So, the thing is, peri-peri
has a very distinct flavor.
It's a specific type of chili.
All I'm really getting
from this is just, like,
chili-pepper heat. No.
You have ketchup.
Can't quite put my finger on it.
I'm going to literally
put my finger on it.
It's got almost more of, like,
a tomato-soup flavor to it,
which I don't hate.
After my preamble about
how much I do not think
ketchup should go with any
of these pizzas, it actually
ended up being my favorite
of these three sauces.
I think that's more of a comment
on the other two not being very nice
rather than the ketchup being good.
You have a variety of four exclusive
delicious dipping sauces.
Butter garlic flavor,
Buffalo ranch,
cheezy jalapeño,
and just regular ranch.
Little Caesars in the UK
also has one dessert option
you won't find in the US,
chocolate chip cookies.
So, we got desserts.
Cookie dough brownies.
One has Twix pieces,
the other has M&M minis.
Very, very sweet.
Kind of weird, actually.
Finally, let's talk about drinks.
In the UK, Little Caesars
carries Coca-Cola branded drinks,
including, obviously, Coca-Cola,
but then also things like
Monster Energy and Oasis,
which is a bit of a British classic.
Comes in either citrus
punch or summer fruits.
It's kind of like a diluted
fruit juice. Refreshing.
Finally, I can have something to drink.
They had Coke products.
We got Pepsi products.
Oh, you know, the classic Pepsi.
Mug root beer, Mountain Dew,
and Starry!
It's the new one. It's
what replaced Sierra Mist.
RIP Sierra Mist, thank God.
Yeah, that's, like, exactly
what 7Up tastes like.
They invented 7Up. Great job, guys.
Unfortunately, Little Caesars in the UK
doesn't give us a full nutritional
breakdown, only calories.
A Hot-N-Ready cheese pizza
in the UK is 1,700 calories.
That's 85% of your
recommended daily allowance.
A Hot-N-Ready US cheese
pizza is 1,950 calories.
That's 97.5% of your
recommended daily intake.
Also, the sodium.
Good Lord.
160% of your recommended daily intake.
The most calorific pizza in
the UK is this, 3 Meat Treat.
A whole one of these
contains 1,910 calories,
or 95.5% of your daily allowance.
We also have the 3 Meat Treat,
but ours is 2,870 calories.
That's 960 calories more
than the UK version.
And ours is 143.5% of your daily calories.
You're not going to believe this.
The 3 Meat Treat isn't
our biggest-caloried pie.
That award goes to, oddly enough, this:
the pepperoni and cheese
stuffed-crust pizza.
This whole thing, 3,340 calories.
That's 167% of your daily calorie intake.
And, of course, the sodium.
The sodium!
380% your recommended daily sodium intake.
So, the pizza's cut in eight slices.
So one slice contains
1,094 milligrams of sodium,
which is almost half of your daily amount
in just one slice.
RIP my kidneys.
A Hot-N-Ready Margherita
or pepperoni in the UK
will cost you £5,
which at the time of
recording this is $6.04.
A Little Caesars Hot-N-Ready pizza
has become a contentious topic
in the US in recent years.
Forever, this was just $5.
But in 2022, they raised the price
for the first time in nearly 25 years.
Price can vary depending on your location,
but where I am here in
Southern California,
a Hot-N-Ready cheese pizza is now $6.49,
or £5.40.
Our most expensive pizzas
are the ultimate supreme,
spicy peri-peri, barbecue
chicken, and 3 Meat Treat,
which will all cost you £10.
This was my first time
trying Little Caesars pizza,
because currently there is only
one of them in the whole UK.
It's in Chellaston, just near Derby.
Having now tried it, and also
with the context of the price,
I think I'm fairly confident in saying
this is a pretty low-rung pizza.
It is very rare to find
anything of this size
for £5 in the UK when you come to pizzas.
But in kind of return for that,
you're not getting the best quality.
I think in terms of my taste
of pizza power rankings
for the UK, this would
be sitting fairly low.
But for £5, it's kind of hard to complain,
because that is quite cheap.
I don't know. How do
you feel about it, Joe?
When researching for this video,
I looked it up, and I was
surprised to find out,
and you might be surprised
as well to learn this,
Little Caesars is the third-biggest
pizza chain in America.
Totally surprised.
Little Caesars recently became
the official pizza of the NFL.
What?
I always thought, this
is just me talking here,
Little Caesars was always
the cheapest option.
Also the quality was never that good.
So I was surprised to learn
that this pizza is, A, still around,
B, very popular,
and, C, after this video, not that bad.
I dogged on Little Caesars for a while,
but, I mean, I've had worse.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Tim Hortons in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Coffees at a UK Tim Hortons
come in three portion sizes:
a small, which is 12 ounces;
a regular, which is 16 ounces;
and a large, which is 20 ounces.
The hot coffee from a US Tim Hortons
comes in four sizes:
small, 10 ounces;
medium, 15 ounces;
large, 20 ounces;
and extra large, 24 ounces.
Harry: Let's measure the
largest coffee in both countries
to see if we're getting as
much as we've been promised.
Irene: It's supposed to be
24 ounces. It's 22 ounces.
So we're missing 2 ounces.
I don't know where they went.
I personally don't care if
there's 2 ounces missing,
but I feel like there are people
who would take this very seriously.
I assume if you're getting an extra large,
you want all 24 ounces.
They've actually only given us 18 ounces.
2 whole ounces missing.
And it doesn't stop there.
This is the Take 12 coffee traveler,
which is the size of a
small child, I feel like,
for when you need 12 cups
of coffee for yourself
or I assume friends,
but probably yourself, honestly.
I don't drink coffee,
so if I drank this whole thing,
I think I would die.
You know how people are like,
"Oh, this is how you'd
kill a Victorian child"?
Like, this is how you would kill me.
I feel like this is what
Joe drinks every morning
if we're being honest.
Tim Hortons' signature Iced Capps
also come in three sizes in the UK,
and they're supposed to be the same sizes
as our hot coffees,
12, 16, and 20 ounces.
When we got these, I was shocked.
I'd never seen one before,
and they kind of look like slushies.
They've sort of melted a little bit
and gone a little bit sad.
Our Iced Capps only come in three sizes:
small, 12 ounces;
medium, 16 ounces;
and large, 20 ounces.
So the same as the UK.
OK, actually really similar to a Coolatta.
Like, very, very similar.
Harry: Again, let's check the biggest one
to see if we're getting as
much as we've been promised.
Oh, there's a big lump.
Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no.
Ah!
Ah.
It's just under 16 ounces.
And it's supposed to be 20,
so we're missing 4 ounces.
Maybe they gave us 4 ounces of
whipped cream. I don't know.
The liquid line is only
actually coming up to,
like, 13 fluid ounces.
There is another line
of, like, foamy stuff,
which takes you closer to 17.
I don't know how much
you can count the foam,
because I feel like
that's not proper liquid.
I don't know enough about fluid dynamics
to know if that's
actually true or not, but
in my mind we've been shortchanged here
13 ounces of actual liquid plus
maybe 3 or 4 ounces of foam.
That's actually really tasty.
This is, like, dangerously good.
I don't want to stop drinking this.
Got a long shoot ahead of us. Let's go.
They're already pretty sweet,
but apparently you can get
these made with chocolate milk,
so you can get it even sweeter.
It's their secret-menu item.
Doughnuts from a UK Tim Hortons
come in three portion sizes:
as a single doughnut, as a box of six,
or as a dozen doughnuts.
These look really good.
In the US, we also get
Tim Hortons doughnuts
in serving sizes of one,
six,
and 12.
Are the doughnuts
themselves a different size
in the US or the UK?
We're going to weigh a
glazed old-fashioned doughnut
to find out.
So close. 68 grams.
God, grow up, Harry.
Whoa.
We're 58 grams.
So we're missing 10 grams?!
It's suspicious. Is your flour heavier?
I feel like you rigged
your scale. I don't know.
I'm going to put out
some conspiracy theories.
Tim Hortons' Timbits come
in three sizes in the UK,
as a box of 10,
as a box of 20,
or our largest size,
[grunts]
as a box of 50.
US Timbits come in four portion sizes:
one,
10,
20,
and 40.
This one is so funny.
I don't think there's Munchkins
with sprinkles on them.
Tim Hortons is kind of gourmet.
Oh, my God.
It's so dense.
This is really good.
These are not like
Munchkins. I take that back.
I'm so sorry, Dunkin'
Donuts, I still love you.
In the Dunkin' Donuts episode,
I tried to fit as many doughnut holes
in my mouth at once as I could.
So you know what this means.
Well, I think it's stupid that
he makes us do this every
time. Such a guy thing.
But yeah, let's beat Harry.
Irene: Mm-mm.
I thought I could fit 10 in my mouth.
They're really dense.
I think if they weren't as
dense, I could put more.
[sighs] I don't want to admit Harry won.
This was rigged!
I don't know how, but it
was definitely rigged.
I don't know, man.
Yeah, OK, Harry, you won.
Whatever. We still won the
Revolutionary War, huh?
Here are the Tim Hortons
menu items from the UK
that you won't find in the US.
And here's everything at a US Tim Hortons
you won't find in the UK.
Harry: We'll start down
this end with the doughnuts.
This is the Canadian maple doughnut.
This is the maple caramel doughnut.
The rainbow doughnut,
the strawberry and vanilla doughnut,
a banoffee pie,
chocolate brownie doughnut,
a caramel apple fritter,
and a red velvet cheesecake doughnut.
These are almost too much
for me, a lot of these ones.
I like a slightly more simple taste
when it comes to doughnuts.
I like just a classic jam.
I think it's the chocolate brownie one
that's calling my name the most.
It's not bad.
The doughnut itself is slightly dry,
as are the brownie chunks on top.
So I think the two of those combined
give a fairly dry doughnut experience.
Maybe a little more sauce in the middle.
Or just wash it down with an Iced Capp,
and then you'll be fine.
We also have some exclusive doughnuts.
Not as many, but, you know, we have four.
This is the honey dip.
Sour cream glazed.
This one does look cool.
Chocolate dip, which,
this does just look like
a chocolate doughnut,
so I don't really understand
how this is exclusive.
And this is the honey,
honey crueler, cruh-ler.
I don't know how to pronounce this.
Actually, we're going to
check that real quick.
Phone: We are looking at
how to pronounce this word
as well as how to say more
interesting and related word.
Crawler. Crawler. Pretty
straightforward once you know.
Crawler. Not crueler, but rather crawler.
And now you know.
I'm probably not saying
it completely right,
but I think we're going to live with it,
because I think if we try
to say it completely right,
it's just going to be worse for all of us.
The honey cruller.
Hm. I didn't taste the honey
at first, but it's good.
I do want to try the sour cream one.
I don't know if I like the sour cream.
You taste the sour cream.
You taste and smell it
right away, I think.
Take a bite?
Take a little bite.
We also have a couple of
exclusive Timbit varieties.
Sour cream glazed Timbit
and the sour cream
blueberry glazed Timbit.
They really like sour cream, huh?
Or do they think we like sour cream
so they're adding it to everything?
It's like when you go
to the "American aisle"
of a grocery store in another country
and it's just all, like,
containers of sour cream.
We also have a load of breakfast options
that you won't find in the US.
We'll start with this one.
It's a veggie sausage and egg muffin.
I gotta say, this looks pretty good.
This is a vegetarian sausage patty
with cheese and egg, as you might imagine.
This is good! Like, the
texture looks there.
It's kind of got those, like,
fibers that you're used to for meat.
Honestly, that's not bad at all.
There is a chance that
you could give this to me
and I would not know that it wasn't meat,
which, for a meat eater, is pretty much
the highest praise that I can give that.
Next up we have an
option called the stack.
So for both the sausage
and the bacon muffins,
you have the option to
turn it into a stack.
What this means is adding a
hash brown into your muffin.
I don't really understand
where the stack thing
came from in the UK, because Tim Hortons
aren't the only ones doing it.
I think Subway also
have, like, sub stacks,
where you can just add
hash browns to anything,
and apparently that makes it a stack.
In the US, we have avocado-toast options.
I was going to hold it up like
the "Animal Crossing" style.
It's kind of flimsy.
You know when they hold up,
like, the fish and they're like,
"This is what I caught."
The bread's just really thin.
I feel like avocado toast usually comes
with a really crusty piece
of bread, like really thick.
Then we're on to breakfast sandwiches,
both in the form of
English muffins and bagels.
There's the double stacked
breakfast sandwich,
which we weren't able to get.
We have the sausage
bagel breakfast sandwich,
bacon bagel breakfast sandwich,
the egg and cheese bagel
breakfast sandwich,
and the bagel BELT,
bacon, egg, lettuce, and tomato.
That's interesting.
I don't think I've ever
heard of that before.
It doesn't look like a bad bagel,
but this isn't the bagel I
would want to go and get.
It doesn't feel right.
Katya: Rubbery?
Yeah, it does feel ...
I don't know if it feels
rubbery, but it's, like,
actually, the inside's a little ...
I don't know about that.
You know, we're filming this in New York.
We have high standards for bagels.
The UK has one breakfast wrap option,
the big breakfast wrap, which
contains a hash brown, egg,
bacon, cheese, and sausage.
That looks like the equivalent of our
loaded farmers breakfast wrap.
It's really stuck in here.
OK, we got it out.
This is hefty.
I wonder why they call ours
the loaded farmers breakfast
but theirs the big breakfast.
Do they think this is
what American farmers eat?
And they're like, "Oh,
that's a big breakfast.
That's what I want today."
I don't think this is
what would keep me going
if I needed to go out
on the farm for a day.
But we can also get the
loaded breakfast wrap
and then the breakfast wrap snacker.
This is so little and cute.
Snack Wrap dupe. Sorry, McDonald's.
Bring it back!
You know, snack size.
That's the right size.
Next up, the UK has bagels on the menu.
You can get these either as
plain or with cream cheese.
I think I did ask for cream cheese
and they might have forgotten it,
and now I just have a very dry bagel,
which I will probably not be eating.
Over here we love our bagels,
and Tim Hortons reflects that
by providing lots of options.
We have the everything bagel,
cinnamon raisin bagel,
the 12-grain bagel,
and a pretzel bagel,
which I don't know if I've seen before.
It's a cool flavor in theory,
and I appreciate the options.
I think it's cool that
they're trying to provide
a good variety for us.
They have more bagel options
than I thought they would have.
If bagels aren't for you
but you want another kind of bread thing,
we also have toast on the menu at a UK,
although they wouldn't
actually give it to me today
because they've run out of the jam
that it's usually served with.
So unfortunately I couldn't get it.
The next one is a classic
British breakfast item,
the bacon roll.
As the name suggests, it's
a bread roll with bacon.
You can get them with a range of sauces.
This one has ketchup,
but I think you can also get brown sauce.
Compared to the standard
fast-food bacon quality
that I'm used to seeing,
this is a pretty thick
piece of back British bacon.
Compared to, like, McDonald's bacon,
this has way more flavor.
Actually tastes of pork,
which is always nice.
We can also get breakfast biscuit options.
We have the simply sausage biscuit,
and then we have the simply bacon biscuit.
I know this is controversial.
Biscuits and scones aren't
the same thing, I'm sorry.
The scones are definitely denser.
I get that they might look similar,
so maybe putting biscuits
with savory things
seems weird, but it's not.
I think you just need to try,
like, a good Southern biscuit.
I say as a girl from New Jersey,
because I clearly know
what I'm talking about.
This isn't a scone.
They're not similar at all.
I'm annoying, so I've
gone to afternoon tea,
here in the US and in London,
so I know the difference.
It's not the same thing.
UK Tim Hortons also sells pancakes.
Now, these are American-style pancakes,
so they are small, round, and
thicker than British pancakes,
which tend to be more like crepes.
They come in portions of two.
This one comes with some Nutella.
You can also get maple syrup pancakes,
which are just the same
but with a little thing
of maple syrup, or
"maple-flavored golden syrup,"
because apparently that's
what we have in the UK.
Or you can get bacon maple
pancakes, which are two pancakes
with bacon and also the syrup.
[laughs]
The bacon pancakes.
Oh, there is more. OK, there's more.
I thought that this was
the only bacon that we had
on our maple bacon
pancakes, but thankfully
they've actually layered it
with some more underneath.
The bacon that you're
getting on the pancakes
isn't the same bacon as you're
getting in your bacon roll.
This is, like, streaky bacon.
That's what we call it in the UK.
Whereas this is what we
would call back bacon,
which has the kind of medallion
and then the little fatty bit on the end.
I'm not sure why they haven't just used
one uniform type of
bacon for the whole menu.
To British people, bacon and pancakes is
kind of a weird combination as it is,
so I don't think it would've
been made significantly weirder
by putting British bacon on these.
We go to the store and get
Canadian bacon, which is ham,
which is I guess this British bacon,
which is, like, what do
they call it? Back bacon?
This is getting overly complicated.
There's bacon, and then there's ham.
That is ham.
Our last breakfast items
are these omelet bites,
which come in spinach and egg whites
and bacon and cheese.
These are basically like
Starbucks' egg bites,
which are good. I love them. But.
Yeah, I feel like the spinach chunks
are kind of big. I don't know.
And then we have the croissant, which,
I don't know if they all look like this,
but it's kind of making me uncomfortable
that the ends are touching.
I feel like they shouldn't do that.
I don't know. It's like when you walk in
on your toothbrushes touching.
Then we have some
sort of breakfast, sort
of snack exclusives.
The chocolate chip muffin.
The fruit explosion muffin.
What fruits are going to be exploding?
It'd be cool if it was
like a Gusher situation.
If you're going to put
"explosion" in the name,
I feel like it should be doing something.
And the wild blueberry muffin.
We also get two cookies
you can't get in the UK,
chocolate chunk cookie
and oatmeal raisin cookie,
which, I still don't know
who would willingly eat
a oatmeal raisin cookie.
Do you eat oatmeal raisin?!
Both of you?!
Well, yeah, that's, like,
no one actually likes
oatmeal raisin cookies.
When someone brings in
oatmeal raisin cookies,
you're hoping it's chocolate chip,
and then when you find
out it's oatmeal raisin,
you're like, what the f---?
I don't get why you would
want raisins in a cookie.
I'm sorry, Katya.
Now, later in the day
you can get lunch options
from a UK Tim Hortons.
Unfortunately, we went
there slightly too early
to actually get these,
but if you arrive later,
here are the exclusive options.
Tims crispy chicken stack,
with or without bacon,
Tims crispy chicken sandwich,
crispy meatless chicken sandwich,
grilled chicken wrap or
a crispy chicken wrap,
a tuna wrap, or a vegan wrap.
Chicken tenders, chicken
and mozzarella panini,
tuna and cheese melt, ham and cheese melt,
tomato and basil soup, or potato wedges.
The lunch options
exclusive to the US include
a tuna salad sandwich,
chicken salad sandwich,
turkey bacon club, ham and Swiss sandwich,
BLT, chipotle steak wrap,
chipotle chicken bacon
wrap, chipotle chicken wrap,
and chili, because, you know,
that's what we really want, I guess.
I do like chili, but that's interesting.
Now let's look at some
drinks you can only find
at a UK Tim Hortons.
'Cause I've only looked at the US menu,
so I'm going to say "only find in the UK."
I bet some of these will
be available in Canada
and there's going to be angry
Canadians in the comments.
How angry can Canadians really get?
I feel like they're
pretty polite in general.
Let's start with some cold beverages.
Over here we have an Iced Capp supreme.
So, a supreme basically means
that they've added some extra
whipped cream and then some
topping pieces to an Iced Capp.
You can get these in a couple
of flavor and topping options.
There was one that was
coconut, for example.
This one is Oreo.
So you get the extra whipped cream
with some little crushed Oreo pieces.
The standard Iced Capp
was already really sweet,
so I'm not sure it needs
Oreo, but, eh, you do you.
We can also get milkshakes
at a Tim Hortons in the UK.
These come in a range of
options, including vanilla,
strawberry, chocolate, maple,
or a dairy-free mango and coconut.
[coughing]
That went down the wrong hole.
That wasn't the shake's fault.
It's, like, banana-y, you know?
Oh, it's banoffee.
Took me a minute, but, hey.
Banoffee shake as well.
Then we have some hot
drink options as well.
Here we have a caramel macchiato.
You can, of course, get
an English breakfast tea.
We're in the UK. You
can't really open a place
and not put this on the menu.
We're continuing the
banoffee-menu-item theme
with a banoffee latte,
which I'm less convinced by.
Yeah, banana coffee
isn't really one that I have tried before.
I guess technically
you could have "banoffee"
to mean "banana coffee,"
but I think if you've got
banana and toffee right there,
just stick with the classic.
We can also get a flat white in the UK.
We can also get a chai latte
and a red velvet hot chocolate.
Sandwich van with "Match
of the Day" music.
[distant music]
Ba ba ba ba, ba da ba ba ba.
Here are our US-exclusive cold drinks.
Cinnamon sugar oat milk cold brew,
vanilla-flavored cream cold brew
with chocolate cold foam,
caramel cream cold brew with cold foam,
mocha cream cold brew with cold foam,
Sunrise Sunset TimsBoost with Red Bull,
Sky's the Limit TimsBoost with Red Bull,
orange tangerine refresher,
fruit smoothie (mixed berry),
and frozen lemonade.
Here are the US-exclusive hot drinks.
The Take 12, which,
coffee's not exclusive,
but you can only get this
giant size in the US,
French vanilla, and steeped tea.
And that's interesting that
the UK doesn't get steeped tea,
'cause, you know, UK.
Apparently this is
really popular in Canada,
and it's just tea that's
made by, instead of brewing,
you leave the leaves in
either cold or hot water,
and eventually the flavor comes through.
But my friend said that this
is really, really popular,
and they have different flavors, so.
I'm going to make a double double.
This is apparently a big thing
in Canada for Tim Hortons,
and it's literally just coffee
with two creams, two sugars.
But it's, like, a thing.
Unless I'm being set up by my friend.
April, don't do this to me.
I'm not strong enough.
Is half and half the same thing as cream?
I think they are, right?
I used to drink half and
half when I was a kid.
I feel like some people
think that's gross,
but it tastes really good.
When I was little, we would go to Denny's,
and it's on the table,
and you're just like ...
It tastes good.
Two sugars.
The few times I do drink coffee,
I usually put six to
eight packets, if that,
but I line them up at once and rip them
so no one can tell how
much sugar I'm putting in,
so they can't judge me.
Maybe it tastes better
when they make it for you.
It just tastes like coffee,
and I don't like coffee that
much, so maybe that's why.
Can I have my diet Coke now?
A large Iced Capp from a
UK Tim Hortons costs £4.39,
which is $5.30.
In the US, a large Iced Capp is $4.89,
or £4.01.
That makes a US large
Iced Capp 7.7% cheaper
in the US than the UK.
Six doughnuts at a UK
Tim Hortons cost £8.99,
which is $10.85.
In the US, six doughnuts cost $8.99,
or £7.38.
20 Timbits from a UK
Tim Hortons cost £7.49,
which is around $9.04.
In the US, 20 Timbits cost $6.29,
or £5.16.
Overall, it honestly seems
like pretty good value
compared to some of the
other fast-food chains
that are comparable, I suppose.
I feel like the breakfast deal
particularly was quite good.
They had a £3.49-ish deal
for a breakfast meal including the muffin,
a hash brown, and a drink,
which is really good.
Probably even better value
than McDonald's, for example.
I really love doughnuts.
I kind of wish doughnuts were
more commonplace in the UK,
because they're not that big a thing.
I feel like from what I've
seen from Tim Hortons today,
they've got what it takes.
They should be pushing really
hard into the UK market.
I do think there's demand for this.
A large Iced Capp from a UK Tim Hortons
contains the following: 399 calories,
23 grams of total fat,
of which 15 grams are saturated,
and 44 grams of carbs,
of which 42 grams are sugars.
That's 20% of your daily calories,
75% of your daily saturates,
and 84% of your daily sugar,
which is alarming,
because it's really good.
A large Iced Capp in the
US contains the following:
393 calories,
23.4 grams total fat,
12.5 grams of saturated fat,
42.7 grams of carbs,
38.2 of which are sugars.
That means that apart
from total fat content,
the US Iced Capp is actually
healthier than the UK's
in every other metric.
Although it's still 62.5%
of your daily saturated fat
and 76.4% of your daily sugar. So.
You win some, you lose some.
Milk.fandom.com.
If you're a huge fan of
milk, that's the place to go.
Oh, here you go. Here's a
table. Thank you, ah, milk.
The milk Wiki is educational.
This is a good opportunity
to explain the differences
between the standard dairy products used
in beverages in the US and the UK.
To me, this is an alarming
amount of saturated fat
because usually when you're
making a beverage like this
in the UK, you'll be using
either semi-skimmed milk
or maybe whole milk.
In the UK, semi-skimmed milk contains
somewhere between 1% to 2% fat content.
And then we have whole milk,
which contains closer to 3.5% to 4% fat.
These are pretty comparable
to the American equivalent.
So you guys have semi-skimmed milk,
but that's, I think, 1.5% to 1.8% fat.
And then you have whole
milk, which is around 3.25%.
What's interesting about
Tim Hortons in the UK
is that they've adopted a
slightly more American approach
to their beverages.
So what they've done is actually made this
with single cream instead of with milk.
The fat content of single
cream in the UK is around 18%,
which I think is around what
half and half is in the US.
But here that is very much the exception
rather than the norm. This is very rare.
You will not see this in many places.
If you're making your beverages
with coffee cream in the US,
that can even range from
18% to 30% fat content.
That's crazy. Honestly, it's tasty,
but I would not want to
drink these every day,
because that is not good for you.
The most calorific Timbit in the UK
is the white chocolate
birthday cake Timbit,
coming in at 94 calories per bit.
One of these also contains
8.5 grams of sugar,
which means that just one of
those and a large Iced Capp
contains your entire
daily sugar allowance.
Also means that I was able
to fit almost 1,000 calories
in my mouth at once. Who knew?
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the
differences between Denny's
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
This is an All-American Slam
breakfast at a UK Denny's.
It consists of two
scrambled eggs with cheddar,
two sausages, two pieces of bacon,
some American-style hash brown,
and two triangles of toast.
This bacon looks a little sad.
I know you guys like
crispy bacon in the US.
An All-American Slam breakfast in the US
comes with the following by default.
Three scrambled eggs with
cheese, two bacon strips,
two sausage links, hash
browns, and a choice
of either four triangles
of toast or two pancakes.
We went with pancakes.
The largest breakfast in the UK is this,
the Grand Slam Slugger.
It's the same as the All-American Slam,
but instead of the toast,
you get two pancakes.
Now, when I saw this on the menu,
I didn't think changing
the toast for pancakes
would actually add that much size to it,
but these things are huge.
I think two of these plus the rest,
and that is a substantial breakfast.
Our largest slam is the Lumberjack Slam.
It comes with two pancakes,
two or three eggs, I can't tell,
grilled ham, you have a
choice of two sausages links
and two bacon strips or four of either,
so I went with four bacon strips,
hash browns, and four triangles of toast.
Look at this.
Now here is a guy who's ready
for a full day of lumberjacking.
You can get some of Denny's
iconic sandwiches in the UK,
including the Grand Slamwich.
We're going to weigh a Grand Slamwich
in both countries to see whose is bigger.
Now, we all know the Moons
Over My Hammy in plate version.
I didn't know this,
but apparently now it's
in sandwich version.
Here it is.
You got the eggs, you got the ham, right?
This is a UK Moons Over My Hammy.
I don't get that pun.
I'm really sorry, guys.
No diner would be complete
without American-style
pancakes in the United States.
An order of pancakes comes
by default as a two-piece.
One, two. One, two.
An order of pancakes in the
UK also means two pancakes.
However, when I went to
order them on the website,
it also gave me the option to add
a single additional
extra pancake for £1.99,
and it let me do that up to 99 times.
So if you do really, really love pancakes,
you can order 101
pancakes from a UK Denny's
for a small, small price of £203.80.
But how big are the pancakes themselves?
We're going to measure them to find out.
So, our pancake, I'm going
to say 16 centimeters across.
And our pancake weighs around 147 grams.
6 inches?
I once caught a pancake this big.
Yeah, again, the Tinder profile, like.
The weight of the same pancake.
This specific 6-inch pancake
at Denny's weighs
148 grams.
Here are all the items
you'll find at a UK Denny's
that you won't find in the US.
And here's everything you'll find
at a US Denny's you
will not find in the UK.
Let's start with the breakfast items.
Our largest slam breakfast,
the Grand Slam Slugger,
is in fact an exclusive.
We have a couple exclusive
slam breakfasts in the US.
The before-mentioned Lumberjack.
I mean, I'm curious about
this fried ham steak.
If you want to eat something at Denny's
that doesn't go straight
for your arteries,
you can get the Fit Slam.
It is two English muffins,
I see spinach, egg whites, tomatoes,
looks like feta cheese. Let's get in here.
I bet that's great when it's hot,
but it is not hot and
therefore it is not great.
Next up we have the veggie breakfast.
In here, we have what
seems to be an omelet
made with peppers, some spinach,
and maybe some onion as well.
There are these little
cubes, almost cubes,
little square things of potato.
And then just a couple of bits of
either boiled or steamed broccoli.
And if you're not eating
eggs, we have a vegan version.
It looks like all they've really done is
just replace the eggs with more potato.
Benny, which is of course
short for eggs Benedict.
Everything needs a fun name in America.
With a poached egg,
ham, hollandaise sauce,
not to be confused with holiday sauce.
That's pretty good.
Of course, we also have a Southwest Benny.
Southwest?
Oh, wait, no, this is, like,
it has, like, chorizo and stuff.
That actually kind of rules.
I'm surprised. That's
actually pretty good.
Something that may mystify the UK viewers,
as you will see various
versions throughout this video
of what I'm about to show
you, biscuits and gravy,
chicken biscuits and gravy.
It's going to be some sort of combination
of fried chicken, or some cases steak,
smothered in the white gravy we have,
a gravy that is filled with sausage
and also on our biscuits.
Deep-fried chicken covered
in our white sauce.
It's a gravy that's sausage-flavored.
Cheese. Not a scone.
Damn it, it's really good.
Next to that is a Santa Fe bowl.
Again, does Santa Fe just
mean, like, salsa and chorizo?
Get these type of potatoes,
these sliced-up seasoned ones.
Also mushrooms and veggies.
Another fried gravy thing.
This is a country-fried steak.
Yes, a steak that has been fried
and put our white gravy on it!
And it also comes with eggs.
Kind of like a big McNugget
that's kind of more beef-flavored.
And speaking of steaks, you can
get a T-bone steak and eggs.
Denny's, what's with the
onions and mushrooms, guys?
I want a steak. Like ...
I assure you there is a
steak underneath this.
Yeah, there it is. There it is. T-bone.
Doorstop of a steak.
Look at the size of this thing.
I mean, this is ...
Man, they destroyed this piece of meat.
This thing is, like,
the most well-done thing
I've ever bit into.
It's like biting into a wallet.
Skip the steak at Denny's.
We have a few omelet options in the UK,
but only one of them is exclusive.
It's the ham and cheese omelet.
I'm surprised you guys
don't have these in America
because I'd say ham and cheese is probably
the most commonly eaten omelet in the UK.
So, we have exclusive omelets of our own,
and they are way more elaborate
than the UK's simple ham and cheese.
Here we have the Mile High Denver omelet,
the Ultimate omelet, and the
Philly cheesesteak omelet.
Now, you watching right now are thinking,
"Hey, Joe, which is which?"
I have no idea.
So another game we're going to play
in this episode is Omelet Roulette.
♪ What's in the omelet? ♪
So I'm going to take a bite of each one
and see if I can guess which omelet it is.
All right.
Denver.
Ham, peppers, onions, cheese.
The next omelet.
I'm seeing sausage.
The question is, does the
viewer want it to be tilted?
I think, if we could put
a poll on the screen.
Should he tilt it?
I think a lot of people
would be like, please don't.
Yeah, this is the Ultimate one.
Sausage, obviously.
Bacon, peppers, onions,
mushrooms, tomato, cheese.
Eh, not bad.
Everything's so wet.
It's dripping with water.
And this one must be therefore
the Philly cheesesteak.
Grilled prime rib, peppers,
onions, mushroom, Swiss cheese.
Ooh, prime.
You will not find the following
pancake options in the UK.
Starting down here,
they got the choconana, which
is chocolate and banana.
Every one of these comes
with, like, eggs and,
again, you just don't get pancakes.
I feel like I want to point this out.
Are you aware, UK? Because I
haven't seen Harry's footage.
Every pancake order comes
with eggs and hash browns and meats.
Look at this. It's
ridiculous. It's so much food.
Next to that is the double berry.
I mean, I see strawberries.
Oh. Because it's a berry pancake.
Ugh. Actually, it's not very good.
The strawberries are weird.
Hearty nine-grain pancakes.
I can't tell how many
grains are in this pancake.
Can you at home?
I have no idea.
And the cinnamon roll pancakes.
I'm sure at this point the
Cinnabon episode is out.
Oh, my God.
Ooh, that's trouble.
That's really good.
And at the end, this is really funny.
It's a crepe. A berry vanilla crepe.
There's something weird
with their strawberries.
We have some exclusive
pancake options of our own.
One thing to point out is that Americans
have this kind of
pancakes-for-breakfast culture,
and that really does not exist in the UK.
Over here, pancake generally means crepe,
so like a thin pancake,
and they're traditionally
more eaten for dessert.
Denny's pancakes in the UK
are the kind of thick American-style ones.
However, the toppings and the sauces
tend to reflect our
dessert-pancake culture a bit more.
We'll start with a
classic pancake topping,
which is Nutella.
I pronounce it "nut-ell-uh."
Some people say "new-tell-uh."
Leon: Who says "new-tell-uh"?
I've definitely — do
Americans say "new-tell-uh"?
Do you guys say "new-tell-uh"?
That's horrible. Please don't do that.
It's "nut-ell-uh."
Over here we have the
double chocolate pancakes.
I think the double chocolate refers to
the chocolate chips in
the pancakes themselves
and also this rather large amount
of chocolate drizzle on top.
Next up, we have some
strawberry dream pancakes,
which have not held up
super well in transit,
I'll be honest.
These are looking less like
strawberry dream pancakes
and more like strawberry
nightmare pancakes.
What is this sauce that's just, like,
fallen off the pancake?
Like, a very sweet
maybe white-chocolate-vanillary-type
cream thing.
Over here, we have the
Oreo cookie pancakes.
I think there are chocolate pieces
or maybe the cookie pieces
in the pancake as well.
Then it's topped with some more
of this kind of sweet
cream stuff they have.
Next up, we have a Kinder Bueno pancake.
Do Americans know what Kinder Bueno is?
It's a chocolate bar.
Very popular in Europe and the UK.
I don't know what the cream
stuff inside of it is,
but one of the best-tasting
things in the world.
And then, finally, because
it's near Valentine's Day
here in the UK while we're filming this,
we can get some Valentine's pancakes.
These red velvet ones.
These are the exact colors that you see
on snakes that you are
supposed to run away from
if you see them in the wild.
We don't have any crepes
on the menu in the UK,
but we do have waffles.
These are also generally
desserts in the UK,
and Denny's serves them
in the following flavors.
Here we have a fresh fruit waffle.
Each one seems to be one
whole circular waffle
cut into quarters and then topped
with powdered sugar and
some other toppings.
With the fresh fruit one you're getting
some banana and some strawberry.
Here we have a golden waffle.
That's a waffle with golden syrup,
which is kind of like a
British version of maple syrup.
Some of the waffles on the menu
also come as Liège-style waffles.
Liège is a place in
Belgium. Belgian waffles.
They're a little bit more dense
than the American waffles.
Next up, we have a Nutella
waffle, not "new-tell-uh."
Then we have a Kinder Bueno waffle.
The sauce stuff really does capture
the flavor of Kinder Bueno.
You can just get a plain waffle
with just some of the whipped butter
that you get with the pancakes.
And then finally, another Liège option
is the banana and salted caramel waffle.
Great flavor combination.
Big fan of that.
Now that we've reset
the table, let's move on
to some other options,
starting with sandwiches.
Start here with the New York melt.
We're more American than the Americans.
Let's try the pastrami.
We're not very good at deli
meats in the UK on average.
Up next, we have the three-cheese melt.
Pretty much just a grilled cheese
with three types of cheese in here.
Here we have the Mac and Me.
This is a grilled-cheese sandwich
filled with mac and cheese and bacon bits.
We've just been discussing
double carbs and established
that there are circumstances
where double carb is OK,
but the bread-pasta combination
in this circumstance
seems to just unsettle me
for some reason I can't
really put a word to.
Then our last exclusive
sandwich is the club sandwich.
You guys do have a club
sandwich in the US,
but I believe it has avocado,
whereas ours does not.
We have a bunch of exclusive
sandwich options in the US.
I mean, the website splits them into
classic breakfast options and
meats and handheld options.
All right, we'll start
with the breakfast one,
the My Hammy Spice.
It's the same thing except
it's got jalapeños in it.
Look at that.
This thing is just dripping with butter.
And then we have the rest,
which I don't think are
supposed to be eaten for breakfast.
They do have a Brisk-B-Q
melt and a Brisk-It-All melt,
which I was not able to get today,
but what we do have is
the Cali club sandwich.
We also got the Super Bird.
What? What is this? Like ...
Turkey, bacon, and tomato and cheese.
Not bad.
The Big Dipper melt.
This is just a, what
looks to be a patty melt
with about half a gallon of au jus.
Look at that.
I love a good patty melt.
That's a pretty good one.
Next up is this monstrosity,
the fried cheese melt.
Now, when I heard that
and put in for the order,
I was assuming it was
going to be like, in a way,
something like grilled
cheese, like they fried cheese
or it's just a funny way
of saying grilled cheese.
No, not at all.
This is actually a
sandwich that consists of
mozzarella sticks.
Look at this. Are you
kidding me? Look at this.
I'm going to take the
top off of one of these.
Look at this.
And it even comes with
marinara sauce, yeah.
It even says in the
script that Harry wrote,
"Mozzarella stick sandwich.
You've got to be kidding me."
We are not kidding you, apparently.
We have one.
That's the stupidest
thing I've ever eaten.
Other sandwiches you can
get that I did not get
include the Nashville hot chicken melt,
the BLT,
and the crispy chicken
bacon ranch sandwich.
In one of the boxes when we
were unpacking everything,
I just found three chicken tenders.
I was a bit confused
because we didn't order
any chicken tenders. I ate
them because I was hungry.
And now looking back I
realize that that was part of
one of our main options,
which is chicken and waffles.
You get a portion of plain waffles
and three chicken tenders
and some maple syrup.
Combine them all, chicken and waffles.
But unfortunately,
already gone. Sorry, guys.
Moving on. We have the
barbecue bacon burger.
It's a single cheeseburger with
two large rashers of bacon.
For the vegetarians, UK Denny's
also has a veggie burger.
Veggie burgers just always
look a bit sad, don't they?
Also, where's the sauce, guys?
Come on. This is dry as a bone.
It smells almost like falafel,
or maybe like a vegetable samosa.
And our last sandwich
option is a chicken burger.
General note here, Denny's,
please sauce your burgers.
These are all quite dry.
But here we have two chicken tenders
with a slice of cheddar cheese in a bun.
This looks like a spaceship.
Is there a "Star Wars" spaceship
that's shaped like this?
That's shaped really, like,
I don't know. I don't know what it is.
Then for the health-conscious among us,
we have two salad options,
starting with the crispy chicken salad.
And a grilled chicken salad.
In the US, we also have a ton
of main-course options
you won't find in the UK.
Didn't get all of them.
I will start with the burgers.
In the US, we have bacon avocado burger.
There's also the before-shown Slamburger.
That's all the Grand Slam
breakfast in burger form.
So weird, yet it exists.
It's got a little egg hanging on here.
Ah!
And the flamin' five-pepper burger.
There's also a bourbon bacon burger
that was not available
at the time of filming.
We also have bowls, bowls, bowls.
So many bowls to choose from.
I only got one.
That's the Mama D's pot roast.
I'm assuming the D stands for Denny's,
or delicious, or deadly.
There's also the crazy spicy bowl
and the bourbon chicken bowl.
Entrées, you saw a lot of
this in the breakfast section,
so I don't have to waste
too much time on it.
First thing we got here is the
Plate Lickin' fried chicken,
and this one I got a
side of mashed potatoes
and a little veggie medley.
The next thing we got
here is the sirloin steak.
Who told you to smother this in
onions and mushrooms?
This is a hockey puck.
Other sides you can get:
fries and a veggie medley.
T-bone steak, you've seen
it, with corn and vegetables.
This right here,
country-fried steak dinner.
Two country-fried steaks
smothered in white sausage gravy,
and, of course, comes with corn,
and I think that's mashed potatoes.
And you can also get
a wild Alaskan salmon.
I'm not bringing cooked
fish in the studio.
Not happening. All right?
Use your imagination.
And you can also get a Cobb salad.
Didn't get that either
because it's a salad.
What about the exclusive
starters and sides?
Well, in the UK it's kind
of like a beige buffet.
Here we have chicken poppers,
just bite-size pieces of fried chicken.
This food is so dry I'm having to
skip ahead to the exclusives,
which thankfully for me
includes beer.
Three of our UK exclusive sides
are actually forms of fries.
Here we have cheesy fries.
Chips and cheese is a
classic British dish,
so I'm glad that they have
localized their menu to the UK.
Then, in addition to the cheesy fries,
you can add bacon to
create cheesy bacon fries.
And on top of that,
you can add jalapeños
to create loaded fries.
This is like a Pokémon
evolving in its three stages.
Cheese fries evolves
into bacon cheesy fries,
evolves into loaded fries.
The Charizard of fries.
Then our last side dish
is a British classic.
It's everyone's favorite, baked beans.
There they are.
These do smell like British baked beans,
so kind of tomato-based
rather than barbecue.
I don't have a spoon.
Should I just sip from this
like a little shot glass?
Leon: They're beans.
They're beans.
Leon: What's that meant
to go with on this menu?
What wouldn't this go with
on the menu, is my question.
Leon: Waffles, probably.
Beans and waffles?
I reckon a bean pancake could work.
You tempted fate here.
Leon: What you're doing is sick.
Charlie: Ugh, God.
[Leon and Charlie laughing]
No, that's bad.
I can't even pretend that was good.
Denny's has boneless wings.
This is what they look like.
I don't know what sauces
they have for dipping.
Nobody asked.
Other exclusive sides
you can get in the US,
you saw all the ones from earlier.
These are ones that you've
probably seen before.
Biscuits and gravy, scones and gravy,
an English muffin, ironically
not in England. That's weird.
We also have right here
this whole-grain rice.
Other sides that we have
either mixed within dishes
you've seen or not seen at all,
wavy-cut french fries,
seasoned cut french fries,
red rustic mashed potatoes.
I saw those somewhere.
The fresh vegetable medley
and the soup of the day,
which is, from what I
remember, beef vegetable,
and they told us couldn't
get it till after 11,
and we picked up the food at 10:45.
Now we're on to the desserts,
starting at the back here
with chocolate fudge cake
with what at one point was whipped cream.
Then we have a few cheesecake options,
starting with a Reese's cheesecake.
Doesn't look very appealing.
They've just kind of dumped
what I assume is this kind of
peanut-buttery, caramel-y
stuff on top of it.
That's not bad.
Moving on from Reese's, we
have an Oreo cheesecake,
so the same cheesecake but with
Oreo pieces crumbled on top.
And finally a Nutella cheesecake.
It has fallen on its side,
so, therefore, I can
prop it up, like a TV.
Then we have some French toast options.
I'm not sure why Denny's
classifies these as desserts,
but apparently chocolaty
pancakes are a breakfast food.
We'll start back here
with Oreo French toast.
French toast, not much of
a thing here in the UK.
What we have is eggy bread, which is like,
the similar start, where
you take the bread,
dunk it in egg, and fry it,
but then we'll have it as a savory dish
rather than as a breakfast/dessert.
Then we have a banoffee French toast.
For the uninitiated,
banoffee is banana and
toffee amalgamated together.
Then we have strawberry
dream French toast.
Fresh strawberries and
some vanillary icing.
Here's three exclusives
you can only get in the US
and not the UK. New York-style cheesecake.
Whoa! Hey, I'm walking here!
The lava cookie skillet.
I'm assuming that's this.
I can't break it.
And it comes with ice
cream, I'm sure for dipping.
Yeah, pretty good.
And the double chocolate pancake puppies.
Like hush puppies, but pancake.
Mm, eh.
Then we have a a couple
more dessert options
and some milkshakes.
Here, we have a strawberry
ice cream sundae
and a caramel ice cream sundae.
Ignore the straw.
I definitely did not
think it was a milkshake.
I think we have identified all the shakes.
I believe this is millionaire shortbread,
peanut butter shake,
a white chocolate and strawberry shake,
cookie shake, a vegan vanilla shake,
then this I think is
Bueno, and this is Nutella.
I think my favorite would probably be
the millionaire shortbread one.
Very sweet but very tasty.
And after all that, the
final exclusive, alcohol.
Thank God.
We can get a few beer
and other alcohol options here in the UK,
including this Coors Light.
I think there's a Peroni beer
and some Kopparberg fruity cider.
Cheers, guys.
According to Dennys.com,
a website I now have an account with,
the nearest Denny's to this
studio in Burbank, California,
an All-American Slam
will run you $15.29.
An All-American Slam from
a UK Denny's costs £10.99,
which at the time of
recording this was $13.23.
That makes the American version
15% more expensive than the UK's.
But there's better value
to be found elsewhere
on the US menu: a stack of pancakes.
These very pancakes. Wow, is this right?
Two of these cost $3.49.
Bro, that is cheap.
Two pancakes in the UK,
that'll cost you £5.79
which is around $6.97.
That means that the UK pancakes
are 99% more expensive.
I don't consider Denny's fast food.
I consider it more of a restaurant
chain, like TGI Fridays.
Even though Denny's does
really lean into breakfast,
it is 24 hours.
So Denny's for me was always a place
that you can go at any time.
Just pretty much anything
you would find in a diner,
you'll find at a Denny's.
I used to go there a lot in high school
because you could smoke in a Denny's,
and it's open 24 hours.
So we'd just drink
coffee, smoke cigarettes,
split an appetizer, and
drive our waitress crazy.
Harry wants to know,
what time of day are
you going to a Denny's?
I think it's more like
what time of your life
are you going to Denny's?
To me, I could be wrong,
but the only people I see at Denny's
are teenagers who want
to get out of the house
and hang out and they
can't get into a bar yet,
and retired people who want
to have a $4 breakfast.
So once you come into
this world on your own,
you start by going to
Denny's with your friends,
then you go off, you live a life,
you have a family, a career,
you make an impact in the world,
and once you retire,
back to the same Denny's.
Full circle.
I like the standalone diner from the '50s,
has some name like Bertha's
or Ethel's or Fred's,
and you have as much
coffee as you want, right?
And a patty melt, fries.
Yeah. That to me — the chain is like, no.
I like the standalone place.
For me, I have to say
this is quite expensive
for what it is.
We don't really have a
diner culture in the UK,
but what we do have is caffs.
Caffs, or short for café,
it's kind of like a
ubiquitous British thing.
You'll find a couple
of caffs in every town
where you can just get a
really cheap and cheerful meal
on the go, in a hurry,
and they'll really, really sort you out,
generally for a lot less money
than what this will run you.
Between caffs and greasy spoons,
which are similar but not quite the same,
we really have breakfast
culture covered in that regard.
That's where you're going
to get your full English,
your toast, your kind
of terrible cup of tea
but in quite a nice way.
Yeah, so I'm not sure Denny's would really
be bringing too much to the table.
When I say we don't really
have much of a diner culture
in the UK, I guess that's
evidenced by the fact
that chains like Denny's really
haven't taken off over here.
We had to actually travel to Wales,
to Swansea to get this one
because that's where our only
Denny's in the whole UK is.
I gotta say, it was kind of
popular when we were there.
It was pretty busy.
Lots of families taking
their kids out for some food.
I think maybe Denny's
currently is just more of a
gimmicky American-style thing in the UK.
If they did try to roll
out, I'm not sure that
it would be really kind of filling a void
that we have that isn't
already filled by caffs,
greasy spoons, or something else.
Unfortunately, Denny's in
the UK doesn't disclose
any of its nutritional information.
Denny's in the US does, however,
so let's take a look
at some menu classics.
One thing to note,
especially with the slams,
is that customizing your order
can drastically change the calories.
For example, take this All-American Slam.
If you choose turkey bacon as your meat,
hash brown as your potato,
and white toast as your bread,
it comes out to 1,050
calories. Respectable.
On the flip side, you can
get the All-American Slam
with sausage links, french
fries — french fries? Come on.
And then upgrade your toast to an order
of cinnamon roll pancakes,
that doubles the calories of the meal,
taking it to 2,300.
That's 115% of your
daily recommended intake.
And the main culprit here,
if it wasn't obvious, the
cinnamon roll pancakes.
Just two of these contain 1,100 calories.
A nutritional-information
document from Denny's
dated back in 2020
also suggested that two
cinnamon roll pancakes
with cream cheese icing
contains 157 grams of sugar.
That's 254% of your daily allowance.
Zoom in for effect.
Gah!
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Kit Kat in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
In the US, our Kit Kats
come in nine sizes.
Yes, really.
Down here we got the
smallest, the minis unwrapped.
Then we go up to the thins.
After that, miniatures.
Right here, we got the snack size,
and then the classic,
standard four-finger Kit Kat,
and then the big Kat,
the big Kat king size,
the king size,
and the XL.
In the UK, classic Kit
Kat comes in three sizes.
As these adorable little bites,
as a two-finger Kit Kat,
or as a four-finger Kit Kat.
In the US, our Kit Kat sizes
come in obnoxious varieties
of units and weights.
Too many to show you today. See?
But let's take a look
at some of the biggest
two- and four-finger
portion sizes you can get.
In the UK, the biggest size
of the two-finger Kit Kats
is this 21-pack.
All of these add up to
around 435 grams of Kit Kat,
half a kilo.
The biggest pack size for
the four-finger Kit Kats
is a 24-pack, totaling
996 grams of Kit Kat,
basically a kilogram.
Although unfortunately, I
couldn't find that today.
The UK will be stunned to learn
the two-finger size is
not native to the US.
The closest thing we
have is our snack size,
which is 7.75 grams smaller.
However, that being said, in the US,
you can get a snack-size
bulk bag of 66 pieces,
which is 916 grams.
And then there's the four-finger size,
which comes in a 36-pack
and is 1,512 grams.
Kit Kat, I have a bone to pick with you.
What is with the packaging
of these new Kit Kats?
These two-finger ones had such
iconic packaging in the UK.
It was wrapped in foil,
and then had this band of
paper going around the outside.
And now they've replaced it with plastic.
Bring back the old packaging.
A four-finger Kit Kat in
the UK will cost you £0.70,
which is around $0.87 in the US.
In the US, one of these costs $1.49,
or £1.20.
That's a 71% cost increase in the US.
71% more expensive in the US!
That's quite rare, particularly
when it comes to snacks.
I feel like in the UK, we
tend to get stung for snacks,
even more so than, like, fast food.
So, hey, we're doing something right.
Imagine if prices of these
went up by £0.50 in the UK.
There would be riots.
Yeah, the streets would be burning.
Here are all the Kit Kat
exclusives you can get in the US
you can't get in the
UK, unless, of course,
your grocery store has
an American section.
Here are all the UK Kit Kats
you can't get in the US,
unless you have access to the internet.
Just about every portion
size that we have,
save for the four-finger
version, the UK does not have.
Get a closer look. The
minis, the unwrapped.
And they want to act
like this is for sharing,
but once your hand goes in
there, it's yours, right?
Also with the minis,
they look a lot like your
UK bites from the outside.
Now, from what I can tell,
the inside of one of these
still kind of looks like a Kit Kat.
Yours look like ...
almost like a Crunch bar.
Does that make sense?
Let's cut to Harry, where he's
just bitten inside of a bite,
and tell us how it looks inside. Harry.
Yeah.
I don't know how much of this you can see,
but you're not getting
the distinct wafer layers
that you're used to from a Kit Kat.
It's pretty much just solid chocolate
with little pieces of biscuity
wafer in there instead.
I'm not quite sure what
the point of the thins are,
because the smaller one has less calories.
But if you have a little bag of them,
you're just going to eat
the whole bag, right?
Oh, God. The hazelnut,
that's not nearly as good
as a regular Kit Kat.
Then we're on to my
personal favorite range,
which is Kit Kat chunkies.
Firstly, you can get a
standard Kit Kat chunky,
but in a duo pack.
This is just a standard
unflavored Kit Kat chunky,
but in a two-pack.
Although they're not
full-sized chunky bars.
There's, like, kind of two,
I guess, maybe two-thirds chunky bars.
So it's still bigger than a standard one,
but not an official double.
Now, this next size we got is the big Kat.
And I know what all you Kit Kat-heads
are saying in the UK right now.
It's not the chunky.
Your chunky is 40 grams.
This one is 42 grams.
And it says right here on the
package, "five crispy wafers."
And, Yuelei, if you can get
a close-up on that pic there.
That is in fact five crispy wafers.
I'm looking at the pic of yours online.
Y'all got four. We got five.
Big, chunky, get outta here!
Firstly, why do you guys
call these big Kats?
Because chunky is a way better name.
It's much more fun. Just
call them Kit Kat chunky.
And then our biggest size, the XL,
which from what I can
tell is three Kit Kats.
It's 12 pieces.
Put the price of a Kit Kat on-screen,
then put the price of the XL on screen.
Is it exactly three times?
Maybe sending one of these to the ocean
is better than sending three smaller ones.
I really don't know.
Then we're on to some of the
exclusive Kit Kat flavors
you can find only in the UK.
We'll start with this one,
which is a vegan Kit Kat.
Hang on. Hang on a minute.
I've only just gotten this.
Vegan Kit Kat, and then right at the top,
there's a little warning label that says,
"May contain milk."
You had one job, guys!
I think I should do a blind taste test.
Charlie has confirmed that
they do look different,
so my eyes are staying closed.
Thank you, Charlie.
This one feels very smooth.
I mean, I'm already pretty
sure that's the vegan one.
I'm confident this is the regular one.
But this isn't bad.
Sometimes when you have a vegan option,
it's, like, actively bad.
This one isn't offensive by any means.
Was I correct?
Charlie: Yes.
I was correct. Cool.
So, we have four flavor options in the UK
which I believe you
will not find in the US.
We have a white chocolate Kit Kat.
That's fine. I'm not the
biggest white chocolate guy.
An orange chocolate Kit Kat.
See, I'm not normally a big
orange chocolate fan either,
but that's not bad. It's
quite a subtle orange flavor,
not too in-your-face.
And here we have the caramel
Kit Kat, which I think is new.
It's pretty good.
I get more, like, honeycomb
than caramel from this.
Definitely sweeter than
the standard Kit Kat.
And a dark chocolate Kit Kat.
I don't normally go for dark chocolate,
but I will eat it sometimes,
and that's not particularly
good dark chocolate.
Four flavors that I have seen before
that currently don't seem
available anywhere online,
couldn't get my hands on them:
apple pie Kit Kat, the
lemon crisp Kit Kat,
the key lime Kit Kat, which is very good,
and, of course, the birthday cake Kit Kat.
But what I could get my hand
on are the Kit Kat duos,
which are different chocolate flavors
on the top and the bottom.
OK, mint and dark chocolate.
Oh, yeah, look at that.
See, look at that.
Yeah, like a Thin Mint.
This is pretty good.
Mocha and chocolate. Mocha and chocolate?
What's the difference
between mocha and chocolate?
That's the difference. Coffee.
Ooh, last but not least,
strawberry and dark chocolate.
Oh, look, it's kind of
like my color palette.
[ominous music]
Mm.
This is the best one.
The next exclusive flavor
is the Kit Kat chunky peanut butter.
These are incredible.
These are one of my
favorite chocolate bars,
I would say, in the UK.
The king of chocolate bars.
Can we get a little crown
on the Kit Kat chunky
peanut butter, please?
Thank you.
The next exclusive chunky
flavor is the caramel.
We also have this in the
standard Kit Kat version.
But let's give the chunky
one a try real quick.
Ooh!
This is very different to
the two-finger Kit Kat.
This one has an actual
layer of caramel in it,
which is kind of what I was
expecting from these ones.
But this one's good.
Next up we have the Kit
Kat chunky white chocolate.
And while I couldn't find
the individual bars today,
you can also get a Lotus
Biscoff Kit Kat chunky.
I was able to find this
in the form of bites,
so I'll give one of these a try
and give my thoughts on the flavor.
I think because you get the
balance of the chocolate
and a little bit of biscuit
in with the Biscoff flavoring,
it's not that bad. It's not overwhelming.
Is it enough to convince
me to start liking Biscoff?
Probably not. But not bad.
Also, you can get Kit Kat sundae cones
and Kit Kat ice cream.
We have no freezer.
I didn't want them melting in the studio.
We actually do have Kit
Kat ice cream in the UK.
I was able to find some in
a Food Warehouse by Iceland.
However, I didn't buy them
because I wasn't going somewhere
with a freezer afterwards,
so would've been melty
and a bit of a disaster.
Here's what they do look like
if you do find them in the UK.
In the UK, Kit Kat offers a
range of seasonal products
depending on which season you're in.
We're filming this in April,
so we've just had Easter,
and they had these adorable
little Kit Kat bunnies on offer.
These came either as a single one
or as a little multipack.
Slightly worryingly, I was able
to find a Christmas Kit Kat
in one of the corner shops that I visited.
Apparently, these are fine
until September this year,
so we're fine.
That's quite cute, actually.
It's quite a nice little design.
The final exclusive I was able
to track down is a fun one.
It's Kit Kat breakfast cereal.
As the packaging suggests, it's new.
I don't think it's in every
supermarket or shop yet.
I had to go to a Waitrose to find this.
They look like little tiny cereal pillows.
I know this is not the fairest
and most accurate way to test cereal,
but they're pretty good.
I was actually able to find
two of your US exclusives, Joe.
I have the Kit Kat birthday cake
and the duos mocha and white chocolate.
As many Brits will know,
our high streets are plagued
by American candy stores,
which are these bizarre shops
which import American
snacks and chocolates
and play really loud music
and I'm pretty sure are a
front for something or other,
but I was finally able to benefit
from them by buying these.
This does have all of those
lovely, forbidden food colorings
that we don't usually get in the UK.
So if I'm really hyperactive
after this, we'll know why.
That is colorful.
Yeah, that's pretty sweet.
[clears throat]
You guys don't hold back
on the sugar, do you?
Yeah, that's, that's excessive.
That's too much, guys. Chill out.
After the birthday cake,
I'm hoping for something
slightly more savory.
Pretty strong coffee flavor.
Yeah, this one's fine. I like this.
A US Kit Kat bar is 210 calories.
It's 11 grams of fat, 7
grams of saturated fat,
20 milligrams of sodium,
28 grams of carbs,
23 grams of sugar, and 2 grams of protein.
In the UK, a standard Kit Kat
bar contains the following:
209 calories, 10.2 grams of fat,
of which 5.6 grams are saturated,
40 milligrams of sodium,
26.1 grams of carbs,
of which 21.3 grams are sugars,
and 2.8 grams of protein.
That's less in every category
other than protein and sodium,
where for some reason we
have double the US figure.
Our most calorific Kit
Kat is the Kit Kat XL.
It contains a total of 640 calories.
In the UK, our most calorific item
is a peanut butter Kit Kat chunky.
One of these contains 226 calories,
which is still less than
half of the US Kit Kat XL.
While Kit Kats are now
beloved all around the world,
they were invented in the UK.
The first modern Kit Kat bar was created
by the Rowntree company back in 1935,
although then it was
called a chocolate crisp.
It wasn't until 1937
that they first used the name Kit Kat,
renaming it to the Kit
Kat chocolate crisp.
The bar exploded in popularity, so much so
that it even survived rationing
during the Second World War.
Despite milk shortages,
rather than halting production completely,
the Rowntrees changed the recipe
to use plain chocolate instead.
So as not to confuse
customers with the new taste,
they changed the packaging
to a blue wartime color.
After the war, when rationing was lifted
and normal production resumed,
they adopted the iconic red color
that we know and love today.
The popularity of Kit
Kat continued to grow,
and they were exported all over the world.
In the 1970s, Rowntree gave Hershey
a license to manufacture and
distribute Kit Kats in the US.
This agreement remained in place
even after Nestlé
acquired Rowntree in 1988.
The popularity of Kit Kat
has actually turned out to be
something of a double-edged
sword for Hershey.
As part of their deal with Rowntree,
if the company is ever sold,
they lose their license to
manufacture and produce Kit Kat.
Kit Kat is the single most popular product
sold by Hershey in the US,
so it makes it much
harder to sell the company
should they ever want to.
My kingdom for a Kit Kat.
In the US, a Kit Kat is made up of sugar,
wheat flour, cocoa butter, nonfat milk,
chocolate, refined palm kernel oil,
lactose (milk), milk fat,
and contains 2% or less of soy lecithin,
PGPR, which is an emulsifier,
yeast, artificial flavor,
salt, and sodium bicarbonate.
A UK Kit Kat has the
following ingredients:
sugar, wheat flour,
which contains calcium,
iron, thiamine, and niacin,
milk powders (whole and skimmed),
cocoa mass, cocoa butter, vegetable fats,
lactose and proteins
from whey, whey powder,
emulsifier sunflower lecithin, yeast,
raising agent sodium bicarbonate,
butterfat, and natural flavorings.
If you've seen the Snickers episode,
you might remember that in the UK,
we tend to feel our chocolate
is of a higher quality
than that found in the US.
It's generally a bit
richer and a bit smoother.
The reason for this is a
higher cocoa and fat content
found in our chocolate.
According to UK rules,
chocolate must contain no
less than 25% cocoa solids
to be considered milk chocolate.
The milk used in each
country's Kit Kat production
also differs slightly.
In the UK, Nestlé uses milk crumb,
which is a dehydrated, slightly
sweetened milk product.
In the US, Hershey uses
nonfat milk and milk fat.
And in the US, the rules
are our milk chocolate must contain
no less than 10% of chocolate liquor,
which is roughly equal part mix
of cocoa solids and cocoa butter.
Unlike most US chocolates,
like Snickers for instance,
our Kit Kats do contain sugar
and not high-fructose corn syrup.
Really?
Yeah.
It's worth pointing out that in the UK,
Kit Kats are made by Nestlé,
while in the US they're made by Hershey.
Furthermore, in 2015,
Hershey did a deal with
Let's Buy British Imports
to stop importing all Cadbury's
chocolate made overseas,
and in the same deal
agreed to halt imports
of so many British
chocolates, like Kit Kat.
Also, and this can be for another episode,
the license agreement allows
Hershey to make, for example,
Cadbury chocolate in the US
with the same packaging as in the UK,
but with a different recipe.
Ooh.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Costco food in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Here is an iconic Costco
hot dog in the UK.
Ah, yes.
The famous Costco hot dog.
In the UK, the length of
a hot dog is 8 inches.
Don't laugh.
Joe: 8 inches.
Almost exactly 8-inch dog.
It's also advertised as a
quarter-pounder hot dog.
Let's see if that's true.
So, with the bun and some onions,
the whole thing weighs 250 grams.
I want to take the sausage
out and weigh that on its own
to see if that is a quarter pounder.
Turns out that without
the bun and the toppings,
it does weigh exactly
a quarter of a pound.
That's pretty impressive.
I know it's manufactured
and mass-made by machines,
but, you know, still cool.
Oh, my God.
It's exactly 4 ounces.
Wow!
They kept it a quarter pound
after it's cooked and everything.
See?
Costco. It's not impossible.
All these people watch
this and they're like,
"Mm, it's a quarter of a
pound before you cook it."
Well, they said 4 ounces.
Whatever they're doing, after it's cooked,
it is the advertised 4 ounces.
Way to go, Costco.
In the UK, a Costco pizza
is 17 inches in diameter.
That makes the surface
area 227 square inches.
In the US, our Costco pizza should also be
18 inches in diameter.
Let's measure it!
More like 17 ½, Costco.
It's still $9.99.
That's a ridiculous deal.
You can keep that half an inch.
Our pizza today was cut into six pieces.
I'd say for a pizza of this size,
it's kind of uncommon
to see only six slices.
I would expect maybe eight
or 10, like at Domino's.
But we're going to weigh one slice
and find out how big it is.
Now let's weigh one slice.
That is a dense slice of pizza.
There's some citation needed,
but this might be the
heaviest slice of pizza
we've ever weighed on "Food Wars."
That's a big layer of cheese.
Not a ton of tomato sauce.
I would say it's maybe 70% bread.
So I don't know if you're
getting a ton of value for money
when it comes to toppings.
I quite like it.
It's got that nostalgic,
cheap-frozen-pizza quality.
The chicken bake.
I don't know what the origin of this is,
but it's a pretty good idea.
It's just, like, a giant
chicken Hot Pocket, right?
The guy holding up the
fish that he's just caught.
We've already used this
gag in a recent episode,
but we can reuse it.
I am curious.
Oh, why is this so good?
This is so good.
I will say, I love stodgy food.
So I feel like I am the target audience
for all of these foods.
The fountain drinks in
the UK come in one size,
and it's supposedly 22 fluid ounces.
Of course, we have to check it.
So, in what seems to be an increasingly
rare occurrence on "Food Wars,"
that is actually as much
drink as we were promised.
That's 22 ounces.
But the fountain drinks in
the US are 20 fluid ounces.
Look at that. It's exactly 20 ounces.
And I filled it up at the thing.
Man, Costco is razor-sharp
with the portions, right?
They're not leaving anything to chance.
Thank you, Costco.
Here are all the Costco
menu items in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
Here are all the Costco
menu items in the US
you won't find in the UK.
Quick disclaimer that the
menus seem to vary slightly
depending on where you
are in the UK or the US.
I got these from the Chingford location
just outside of London,
and Joe's got his from the
Burbank location in California.
We have one exclusive pizza
option in the UK from Costco,
and it's this one, the
barbecue chicken pizza.
As the name suggests, it's
a barbecue chicken pizza,
which also comes with
some green bell peppers
and some red onion.
When I see a barbecue pizza in the UK,
I usually grimace because it tends to mean
that the sauce is barbecue,
and I don't like that.
But I think here, they've
actually just kept
the same cheese and tomato base
but added the barbecue toppings on top,
which in my opinion is what
a barbecue pizza should be.
Leon does not agree.
It still feels pretty hefty.
Maybe not quite as dense or as hefty
as the cheese pizza did.
The dough seems to be not quite as thick.
Try just the chicken on its own first.
It's not bad. I'm not getting much
barbecue flavor from that.
It's more just like a
sort of grilled chicken.
Usually my biggest
complaint of barbecue pizzas
is that they're too barbecuey,
whereas this one actually
isn't very barbecuey at all.
That means that I like it.
But if you do normally like quite a strong
barbecue-sauce flavor from your pizzas,
this one might not be enough for you.
In the UK, you can also get whole pizzas
as part of a family bundle.
The bundles come with a full-size pizza,
one of these gigantic garlic breads,
two of these garlic-and-herb dips,
and also a 2-liter bottle of Pepsi Max,
half of which I have spilled
on the floor of the studio.
Twisted churro.
We got these, you guys don't.
It's not a lot of stuff. All right.
This thing, churro, cinnamon, dough.
Mm.
Next up we've got Costco's
take on a classic British dish,
cottage pie.
Now, our American viewers may
have heard of shepherd's pie.
Cottage pie is basically the same thing
in that it's a layer of
some cheese on top, usually,
some mashed potato,
but instead of the lamb-mince mixture,
cottage pie contains beef mince.
Now, this is a classic British dish,
and we do feel pretty passionately
about things like this.
So let's hope Costco have done it justice.
The strategy seems to be
sell large quantities of food
but really pack it with
the kind of cheap stuff.
So, for example, there's a small amount
of cheese on top here,
a very small amount of beef on the bottom,
and I'd say, like, 80% of
this is just mashed potato.
Let's give it a try.
It's actually quite tasty.
I don't work for Costco, I just,
I'm a truth seeker.
Again, the beef is, like,
it's very rich, it's quite thick,
but there's a real meaty flavor to that.
Is it the best cottage
pie you've ever had?
No, probably not.
But is it an affordable, filling version
that's fairly true to the original?
I'd have to kind of say yeah.
You do get kind of more filling
as you go into the middle as well.
It wasn't all like that, thankfully.
Yeah, I don't know.
I actually don't think they've
done too bad a job here.
Next up we have this one,
which is the double
chicken fillet sandwich.
Considering the theme of just hefty foods,
this thing is absolutely massive.
Look at it!
Yeah, I think maybe they were supposed to
stack the chicken patties
instead of laying them side by side,
'cause the bun barely covers any of it.
They've also only put one
slice of cheese on it,
so only about 40% of it
is covered in cheese.
I might have to do some quick
tactical rearrangement here.
Oh, there's maybe ...
oh, there's another bit
of cheese on the bottom,
so you get cheese.
Oh, God.
But then it's like, can you eat this?
Because that is also a
logistical nightmare to eat.
I think whichever way you stack this,
it's going to be quite tricky to eat.
But this is the double
chicken fillet sandwich.
There are two chicken
fillets, two slices of cheese,
some lettuce, and some tomato.
Extremely dry.
Very bland.
Like, none of the components
taste of anything, somehow.
It's a bit of a miss.
Again, it's like, it's
big. It would fill you up.
Next up we have the
Korean barbecue beef bake.
So it's like the chicken bake
in that it's kind of a baguette
with some cheese on top filled with meat,
but instead of chicken and bacon,
this one has Korean barbecue beef.
I imagine it's going to be a
similar level of stodginess
to the chicken bake and
also to everything else
that we've eaten today.
The filling on its own
doesn't really taste of much,
which is slightly disappointing.
That's bland. That's disappointing.
I'm still eating it, but it's bland.
It's just, like, nothing
that jumps out to me
as Korean flavors in this.
If you're going to make
something that bland,
I think don't drag Korea through the mud,
just call it a beef bake
and be done with it.
There's one other classic British dish
on the UK Costco menu,
which unfortunately they
forgot to give me today,
and it's jacket potatoes.
There's a note in the
script where Joe says
that he doesn't know
what a jacket potato is,
so I'll do my best to just
explain it to you now.
As the name suggests, it's
basically just a potato
that you keep in your jacket
in case you get hungry.
These can either be boiled or baked.
You'll usually wrap it in some foil
just so that it doesn't
kind of touch anything else
that's in your pocket.
Keep it on you, and then
whenever you get hungry
during the day, you have
a nice snack with you.
As the name suggests,
it's basically a potato that
you keep in your jacket.
[crew laughing]
We also have two exclusive
dessert style options in the UK,
including a caramel fudge sundae
and a coffee caramel frappé.
I didn't get either of them today,
but here's what they look like.
Ahem.
Two cold drinks you can
get here in the US Costco
is the fruit smoothie.
Oh, my God, that's great.
Mm!
Wow, that's really good.
And the cold brew mocha freeze.
Oh, boy, that's melted.
I'm really surprised how
good these cold drinks are.
I mean, their food is good,
but these are really good.
Mm.
Yeah, that's picking me up.
That's picking me up, Yuels!
Let's go!
Ah!
Now I need to calm down a little bit.
And finally in the UK,
we also have mango smoothies on the menu,
although today their machine was broken.
They weren't serving them.
Here's what they look like.
Want to take this moment
to talk about Kirkland,
Costco's signature brand that provides
a wide variety of products for a low cost.
Over the years, the brand has
developed a loyal fan base
among Costco members.
It would be impossible to
feature all the Kirkland
food and beverage items exclusive
to the US not in the UK.
And believe me, I begged management
to let me sample Kirkland's
many alcohol options,
to which they said, "No way."
So here are a few non-alcohol
Kirkland signature
favorite exclusives in the US.
Going to start here: animal crackers.
I mean, come on, UK.
Who doesn't love animal crackers?
Are animal crackers popular
in the United Kingdom?
Oh, my God, let's do the animal review.
I think monkey. Gorilla?
Orangutan?
This looks like a hippo.
We got hippo.
Oh, this is most certainly a koala.
I've seen that guy already.
We're already getting repeats.
Alligator, I think.
Possibly a dragon.
A Brookfield Zoo all
on your fingertips here
in cracker form. Fantastic.
And the US is not playing
with their cheese selection.
So many.
And the one according to the internet
that just everyone is raving about
is, of course, the Parmigiano-Reggiano.
Parmigiano-Reggiano.
1 ½ pounds.
How much do you think a 1 ½-pound
block of Parmigiano-Reggiano costs?
Go.
What do you think?
Actually, it was $16.
Jeez, both of you.
I thought everyone was
going to be like, "$50!"
No, $16. That's still really good.
16 bucks for all this?
I mean, this is going to last, man.
This will last many of your
wine and cheese parties.
And, of course, Costco has a
fantastic selection of wine,
all of which I'm not allowed
to go near, apparently.
According to management.
All right? This video would
be a lot more entertaining
if we were doing the wine review.
Peanut butter, peanut
butter, peanut butter.
When I went to the UK,
I'm not kidding you,
every person I talked to
when they realized I was an American,
which was literally one second
after I opened my mouth,
they all asked me the same thing.
"What is with Americans
and peanut butter?"
Is peanut butter not popular in the UK?
They were like, "You guys put
peanut butter in everything."
We kind of do.
This is really good peanut butter.
Please forgive me, all the
peanut butter heads watching.
Do you want it this liquidy?
'Cause I'm thinking
peanut butter sandwiches,
peanut butter and jelly,
peanut butter and honey,
whatever you're mixing the
peanut butter with, right,
you want some thickness to
it to stay on the bread.
Do we want thin peanut butter?
I don't know. I'm asking you, the viewer.
What is the preferred
viscosity of peanut butter?
I mean, this is creamy,
but I mean, like, cream creamy.
Italian sparkling mineral water
with carbonation added.
If anyone was wondering
just how boring I am,
my favorite sparkling water
is actually the non-flavored.
Right?
Like, LaCroix, my
favorite one's the plain.
That's right, you better "ugh."
I just like the bubbles in the water.
Mm.
Smells Italian.
Oh, yeah, it's really
harsh. This is very good.
Joe: Mm-hmm.
Like, I want that
harshness of the bubbles.
What are you "ewwing" about?
Speaking of Italy, pesto.
So, the basil was imported,
but I don't think this was made in Italy.
Basil. People swear by this stuff.
They swear by it.
Dried mango slices.
This right here, look how many
of these they gave me, man.
This is 2 ½ pounds
of dried organic mango slices.
I am a mango boy.
That's an impressive list of stuff.
We don't have that many
Kirkland exclusives in the UK,
but there is one interesting one I found,
which is this hazelnut spread.
This is just Costco's version of Nutella.
Not "new-tell-uh."
Well, it was interesting
because I was looking at
the ingredients of this,
and the percentages kind
of piqued my interest.
So out of interest, we
googled what the contents
of real Nutella are,
and the ingredients said
that there were 13%
real hazelnuts in there
as well as 7.4% fat-reduced cocoa powder.
So if we compare it to this one,
Leon, how much hazelnut
do you think is in this?
Thirteen percent.
Exactly the same.
Fat-reduced cocoa powder, 7.4%.
So on paper, this has
basically identical ingredients
to real Nutella.
I mean, it smells and
looks a lot like Nutella.
I would struggle to tell
this apart from real Nutella
in a blind taste test, and it is cheaper.
So, hey, next time you're around
and you really, really love Nutella,
you can buy it in bulk here,
and you won't really know.
I also found some products
which weren't Kirkland brand
but did pique my interest.
Marmite.
I found this kind of
catering-size tub of Marmite,
which I could not resist.
I assume this is an exclusive
and not something that
you'd find in the US.
Not 100% sure.
Made Marmite pasta and put
it on Instagram yesterday
and people got upset, so it felt relevant.
And I also found some
American products at Costco
that you wouldn't normally
see on British shelves.
For example, Skippy brand peanut butter.
This isn't bad, but, like,
there's so much oil in here.
You can see it's, like,
running off the top,
and it's kind of made the
whole thing go very liquidy.
According to the ingredients,
this is 10% hydrogenated palm oil,
which might go some way to explaining
why it's so liquidy at room temperature.
These caught my eye while
I was browsing the shelves.
Smucker's Goober?
Neither of those are
real words, first of all.
But this is peanut butter
and grape jelly stripes.
Is this what Americans
are putting in PB&Js?
It claims to be "America's
favorite combination
peanut butter and jelly."
How much competition do
they have in this field?
I'd love to know.
Americans love grape-flavor things,
and it's really not common in
the UK for whatever reason.
I mean, it's quite pretty.
I'd love to see the machine that
puts this into the jar in that pattern.
This is a lot more solid.
I think they've added gelling
agents and stuff to this
to keep it in that uniform shape
with the cool color pattern.
The grape jelly is extremely sweet,
and the peanut butter,
even I think on its own,
is quite sweet compared
to the Skippy as well.
I want to give a disclaimer.
Although this is the exclusive section,
I don't think these are exclusive.
I just know that one awesome thing
about the Costco here in the US,
I don't know if it's in the
UK, Harry can confirm this,
is they have ridiculously
good baked goods.
Costco's in the US is also
famous for having a sheet cake.
Couldn't get it. You gotta
order it ahead of time.
I'm sorry. Let's get a
picture of that on the screen.
With my face on it.
But they have so many
muffins and croissants
and other things.
I heard really good things about
the bakery section of Costco,
so I also had to give that a try.
This goes out to Katya's dad.
Our producer Katya,
apparently her dad really
loves Costco croissants.
I feel like these would
benefit significantly
from being heated up.
It's not bad, as far as
pre-packaged croissants go.
And finally, these cookies.
You get chocolate chip,
double chocolate, and white choc chip.
In the UK, a lot of our
pre-packaged cookies,
for whatever reason,
tend to be really solid,
and you can snap them
rather than chew them.
But this is the much softer
American-style cookie,
which is really good.
Full disclosure, this is the first time
I've ever shopped at a Costco.
And it's not a snob thing.
See, I grew up, my dad
worked for a grocery chain,
and then I move out into the world,
and the thought of having
a case of toilet paper
or bottled water in my
shoebox apartment was crazy.
Also, $60 for a membership?
I mean, I was just scraping by,
so coming up with $60
to go grocery shopping
was madness for me, so.
And then just never went
until now for this video.
And I think Costco's really awesome.
I like it now. Shout-out to Kirkland.
Costco in the UK is a little bit weird
because not just anyone can
actually walk into a Costco.
You have to actually apply
for warehouse membership,
which is different to just
standard online membership.
And to do that, you have to be working
in a certain number of
limited professions.
Some of the professions make sense.
It's things like teachers,
who maybe work in a school
and need to buy supplies,
and some of them are really random.
Things like airline
workers are allowed in.
I think I was technically
allowed in as a journalist,
so this is journalism, if anyone asks.
I believe a year of standard
individual membership
costs around £30, maybe slightly more.
There's different tiers as well.
You can get, like, executive membership,
where you unlock certain perks.
Honestly, I don't really
know why it's set up
exactly this way in the UK.
I guess they want to
kind of have some control
over the foot traffic in the stores.
They don't want everybody
just piling into the store.
I went at 11 a.m. on a Tuesday,
and it was really busy,
and I asked someone on the till,
and they said that that wasn't
even busy by their standards.
I think this is what it's like in the US,
but the shop itself was just
basically an enormous warehouse
with stuff everywhere.
It wasn't organized hugely well.
The aisles weren't particularly labeled.
There were numbers on the aisles,
but didn't say what was in them.
So I just kind of had to snake around
and try and find what I could find.
Things were slightly
cheaper in there than usual,
but I don't even think things
were massively discounted,
particularly the branded stuff
compared to the Kirkland stuff.
So I think you're more just going
because you need to buy things in bulk
and it's slightly more convenient,
rather than because you're
trying to save a lot of money
on your day-to-day groceries.
For me to be able to sign up for this,
they needed to see a pay slip
so they could prove who I was employed by.
Kind of weird.
A whole pizza from a UK
Costco will cost you £9.99,
which at the time of recording was $12.38.
A Costco pizza in the US is $9.95,
or £8.03.
That's a 19.9% price decrease in the US.
The Costco hot dog here in the US
with a 20-ounce soda is $1.50,
the same price it's been since 1985.
How has Costco managed to sell them
for so low for all these years?
In an age where seemingly everything
has been hit by inflation,
the Costco hot dog has become
somewhat of a viral phenomenon.
Their commitment to keeping
the hot-dog combo at $1.50
is so strong that, as the story goes,
when the current CEO
approached the old CEO
about possibly raising the price,
he said, "If you raise the
price of the f---ing hot dog,
I will kill you. Figure it out."
And they did.
Costco would soon switch from selling
Hebrew National hot dogs
in their food courts
to manufacturing their own.
They opened a hot-dog factory
in LA, then in Chicago,
reducing production costs
and keeping the hot dog
at the $1.50 price point today.
It is fair to point out that
our hot dog costs £1.50,
which is more like $1.86.
It does come with two more ounces of soda,
so maybe that's why,
or maybe Costco just likes the aesthetic
of having 1.50 on the sign.
A slice of pepperoni pizza from
a UK Costco is 826 calories,
while a slice of cheese pizza is 751.
The most calorific thing on the menu
is a whole pepperoni pizza.
A whole pepperoni pizza is 4,962 calories,
which is 248% of your daily allowance.
A slice of pepperoni at Costco
in the US is 650 calories.
A slice of cheese roughly the same size
will be 710 calories.
That's 60 calories more.
Hm.
Does that make sense that the cheese
is more calories than the pepperoni?
I gotta.
Mwah.
A UK chicken bake is 911 calories.
An entire US chicken bake is 840 calories.
A UK hot dog is 602 calories.
The hot dog and 20-ounce soda in the US
is 580 to 850 calories
depending on the drink you get.
So least calories would
be, of course, diet Pepsi,
which has zero calories.
If you got a regular Pepsi,
that'd be 250 calories.
And if you wanted to get the
most calories in your drink,
that of course would be 280 extra calories
if you got the Tropicana fruit punch.
I've been asked by my producer
to wipe up the crumbs.
One thing Little Caesars
didn't provide were napkins.
That's OK.
Let me wipe my mouth real quick.
Mm!
This video, sponsored by Domino's.
Ah!
Caesar!
Et tu, Brute?